es hat ja sehr viel Kritik gegeben an
dem Vorhaben der zukünftigen
ampelkoalitionäre die epidemische Lage
nationaler Tragweite aufheben zu wollen
bzw deren Feststellung und die Kritik
daran ist ja gewachsen in den
vergangenen Tagen angesichts der
zunehmenden Höchstwerte was die
Ansteckungen durch Corona angeht sie
haben es in ihrer Moderation ja eben
gesagt und eben haben außerdem ist ja
auch noch interessant die große Frage
wie wird sich im Olaf Scholz
positionieren was seine neue
bund-länderrunde angeht und auch was er
von 2G oder 3g-regeln hält auch da sind
die Koalitionäre ja durchaus
unterschiedlicher Auffassung gewesen
zumindest im Vorfeld das könnte also
eine turbulente Sitzung werden heute für
die neue Bundestagspräsidentin für
Bärbel Bars und ja da wird sie sich
sicherlich gut vorbereitet darauf haben
und über dieses Thema aber auch über das
Thema Pandemie und ihre Vorhaben für
diese Legislaturperiode als
Parlamentspräsidentin konnte ich mit ihr
sprechen aus der minengründen haben wir
das Gespräch gestern Nachmittag
aufgezeichnet
Frau Bundestagspräsidentin danke dass
Sie sich Zeit nehmen für dieses erste
längere Fernsehinterview an diesem
Donnerstag werden sie ihre erste
reguläre Sitzung im Plenum leiten mit
welchen Erwartungen mit welcher
Vorbereitung gehen sie da rein also zum
einen haben mich die Mitarbeiterinnen
Mitarbeiter sehr gut vorbereitet auf
diese Sitzung also dass man auch immer
weiß welche Knöpfe man drückt und das
auch in der richtigen Reihenfolge und
auf der anderen Seite erwarte ich dass
wir auch direkt eine
Geschäftsordnungsdebatte zur ersten
Sitzung haben und darauf bin ich aber
auch gut vorbereitet aber es wird schon
was anderes sein wenn man das Plenum von
dieser Seite verfolgt als bislang der
Fall gewesen ist
das stimmt aber es hilft natürlich wenn
man zwölf Jahre im selbst im Bundestag
ja da an den Debatten teilgenommen hat
weiß man natürlich auch was ein
Präsident oder eine Präsidentin in der
Sitzungsleitung zu tun hat das bekommt
man zwangsläufig mit und jetzt sitze ich
halt in einer anderen Rolle und muss
natürlich auch neutral und
fraktionsübergreifend im Zweifel
einschreiten wenn es nötig ist
das Angebot Parlamentspräsidentin zu
werden ist ja alles in allem dann doch
ein bisschen aus heiterem Himmel
gekommen sie haben gesagt sie das war
ein Angebot dass ich mich ablehnen
konnte sie haben aber auch hier im
Plenum schon gesagt sie haben im
richtigen Moment ja gesagt wie lange
haben sie trotzdem gebraucht um zu
diesem Jahr zu kommen das ging wirklich
schnell also ich habe die Frage gestellt
bekommen und natürlich ist dieses Amt
sehr attraktiv und dann habe ich
wirklich sofort ja gesagt allerdings war
ich insofern nicht vorbereitet weil ich
mit meiner Funktion die ich vorher hatte
als stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende für Gesundheit
Bildung und Forschung da habe ich nicht
nach einem neuen Amt gesucht also das
hat mir schon sehr gefallen und das
hätte ich auch weiter gemacht aber als
ich das Angebot bekommen habe habe ich
in der Zeit sofort ja gesagt sie sind
die dritte Frau in diesem Amt nach
annemarie Renger und Rita Süßmuth sind
die beiden Vorbilder für Sie
ich glaube jede Person die diese
Position hatte hat so einen eigenen Stil
und eine eigene Rolle aber auch die
beiden Frauen vor mir haben dieses Amt
sicherlich in ihrer Art und Weise
geprägt und insofern ist es schon ein
Stück weit Vorbild einfach weil eine
Frau vielleicht auch andere Themen
mitbringt die man dann in diesem an
vielleicht auch ausüben kann und
insofern sind sie Vorbilder und ich bin
auch erst die dritte das ist wenig ich
hoffe dass es in Zukunft häufiger zu
wechseln kommt und dass das keine
Seltenheit oder Besonderheit mehr ist
sind wir schon bei einem wichtigen Punkt
den sie genannt haben in ihrer ersten
rede hier am Tag der konstituierenden
Sitzung weil sie gesagt haben es sei
eine besondere Aufgabe auch für sie
Frauen in der Politik zu stärken mehr
Frauen in die Politik zu bekommen wie
wollen sie das anstellen
ja zum einen reden wir ja in dieser
Legislatur hoffentlich um eine
Wahlrechtsreform und das eine ist
natürlich dass man auch über einen
Wahlrecht und Listen Aufstellung wenn
sie paritätisch besetzt werden dann auch
mehr Frauen in die Parlamente bekommt
aber in meiner Funktion selber auch in
meiner öffentlichen Darstellung will ich
natürlich auch ein Vorbild sein für
Frauen die vielleicht zögern oder nicht
so schnell ja sagen wie ich das tue oder
eben auch Frauen ermutigen selbst wie
annemarie Renger ist getan hat selbst
den Finger zu heben und zu sagen ich
kann die Tiere haben Sie konkrete Ideen
auch wie man das realisieren oder wie
man das fördern kann na es gibt ja hier
auch schon verschiedene Kreise auch wo
Frauen sich untereinander austauschen
auch über die Fraktion hinweg wo man
natürlich auch im parlamentarischen
Verfahren versucht
übergreifend Frauen politische Themen
auch zu setzen und das will ich gerne
fortführen und mich auch da gerne dran
beteiligen sie haben die
Wahlrechtsreform eben angesprochen in
der einen Antwort an der sich sowohl
Norbert Lammert über mehrere
Legislaturperioden als auch Wolfgang
Schäuble ihr direkt der Vorgang nach
gerade die Zähne aus Gewissen haben
haben sie neulich mal gesagt irgendwie
jetzt wollen wir aber richtig eine
machen und nehmen sie denn die
Zuversicht her dass es jetzt klappt also
erstens glaube ich dass oder das spüre
ich auch dass bei fast allen oder allen
Fraktionen schon der Wille ist dass
dieses Parlament nicht immer weiter
wachsen kann das ist erstmal eine
Grundvoraussetzung die ist glaube ich
über die letzten Jahre auch erst
gewachsen auch bei den allermeisten
Fraktionen und es liegen jetzt wirklich
viele Vorschläge auf dem Tisch also man
muss jetzt auch nichts mehr neu erfinden
und meine große Hoffnung ist wirklich
das erstens meine Vorgänge auch schon
sehr gut daran gearbeitet haben aber
dass sie Koalitionsfraktionen die er
jetzt noch in den Verhandlungen sind
dass möglicherweise da auch schon ein
Vorschlag kommt den man dann hier im
Parlament auch beraten kann mit allen
anderen Fraktionen und dass wir
tatsächlich
das dann auch relativ schnell umsetzen
also sollte da nichts kommen sage ich
auch direkt dann ist schon auch mal an
Sinn dass ich die Fraktion dann recht
schnell nach der Konstituierung der
neuen Bundesregierung einladen werde
soll ein Kommission geben meine ich
gelesen und gehört zu haben was soll die
machen wenn sie sagen es ist ja im
Grunde schon alles liegt ja alles auf
dem Tisch oder es liegt viel auf dem
Tisch es gab sogar ein Alternativen
Gesetzentwurf von FDP grün und Linken in
der letzten Legislaturperiode im Grunde
ist ja alles da das ist ja auch meine
Position das sage es ist alles da es
muss nichts neu gemacht werden aber die
Kommission kann vielleicht noch mal
einen versöhnenden Vorschlag machen der
dann auch breit getragen wird aber wie
gesagt ich spüre auch bei Fraktionen die
bisher zögerlich waren dass die Einsicht
doch schon da ist dass man in dieses
Parlament nicht enorm wachsen kann weil
es ja auch um Mitarbeiterinnen
Mitarbeiter geht um Räumlichkeiten aber
auch um Abläufe im Moment funktionieren
die Abläufe noch bei 700 über 700
Abgeordneten aber wenn es mal 800 oder
900 werden dann kriegen wir einfach auch
große Probleme das alles raumtechnisch
und auch in Abläufen unterzubringen wo
wohl die Beharrungskräfte bei einigen
Fraktionen ja und auch bei einigen
Parteien in der letzten
Legislaturperiode enorm gewesen sind und
man sich dann natürlich fragt irgendwie
die werden davon nicht sonderlich
abweichen insbesondere wenn da ihre
produktionsstärke von abhängt ja aber
auch die die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
erwarten das und das spüren wir auch als
Abgeordnete also ich bin auch direkt
gewählt und natürlich will ich das gerne
behalten und verteidigen aber auf der
anderen Seite habe ich auch viele
Gespräche mit Bürgern Bürger die sagen
das ist nicht mehr zu gewährleisten dass
wir zu groß und wir sind dann irgendwann
das größte Parlament der Welt wenn wir
so weitermachen und da muss eine
Begrenzung rein ich will gar nicht so
weit gehen dass man sagt wir gehen auf
die begrenzte Zahl die im Wahlrecht
steht sondern vielleicht kann man sich
da auch auf eine gewisse Größe jetzt
einigen und das ist eigentlich die
Absicht dass man wenn man sich auf eine
bestimmte Größe einigt die ihr dann fest
schreibt dass es dann auch tatsächlich
zu einem echten Deckel kommt sie haben
sich große Ziele gesetzt einmal was die
Förderung von Frauen angeht auch in der
Politik auch jetzt mit dieser
Wahlrechtsreform da lohnt ein Blick auf
die Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten die dieses
Amt der Bundestagspräsidentin eigentlich
hat wie schätzen Sie das ein gerade am
Beispiel Wahlrechtsreform haben wir
gesehen wie gesagt habe es angesprochen
Norbert Lammer und Wolfgang Schäuble
haben sich da immer sehr stark gemacht
irgendwie sind aber trotzdem nicht
durchgedrungen damit also so viel Kraft
und wie viel Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten
sehen Sie in diesem in ihrem neuen Amt
also ich will mich in Tagesgeschäft
nicht einmischen das ist glaube ich auch
nicht meine Rolle aber es wird
sicherlich immer parteiübergreifende
Themen geben wo man dann auch als
Präsidentin einmal ein bestimmtes Thema
auch anpacken kann bei der
Wahlrechtsreform ist es so dass ich mich
nicht verstehe jetzt mit eigenen neuen
Vorschlägen zu kommen sondern es sind
alle da und meine Rolle sehe ich eher so
dass zielführend zu moderieren also
wirklich die Beteiligten noch mal einen
Tisch zu bekommen und tatsächlich an
einem Kompromiss zu arbeiten der dann
für die allermeisten tragfähig ist und
so stelle ich mir dieses Amt auch bei
anderen Themen vor die jetzt nicht ins
Tagesgeschäft der Regierung eingreifen
sondern wir sind das Parlament und
insofern ist meine Aufgabe er zu sagen
dass wir unsere Rechte als
parlamentariererin und Parlamentarier
wahrnehmen und auch auch gegen eine
Bundesregierung die uns ja diverse
Gesetzes vorliegt und da bin ich ja nach
wie vor auf das alte drucksche Gesetz
stolz dass nichts so aus dem Parlament
kommt wie es reingekommen ist und daran
zu arbeiten ist in erster Linie meine
Aufgabe aber eigentlich bleiben ihnen
eigentlich nur reden Appelle und
vielleicht auch Interviews und gutes
Zureden bei denen die sie gut kennen ja
und das andere sind natürlich auch
Möglichkeiten das habe ich ja auch schon
angesprochen dass ich auch auf
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zugehen will dass
ich dieses Parlament auch nach außen
stärker vertreten will ins Gespräch
kommen mit Schülerinnen und Schüler also
auch junge Menschen für dieses Parlament
und die Arbeit im Parlament zu
interessieren insofern habe ich schon
auch eine Rolle wo ich auch sichtbar
sein kann wo dieses Parlament vielleicht
auch für viele die sich von der Politik
abgewandt hat wieder interessant werden
kann und das habe ich mir zumindest
vorgenommen auch über bürgerräte das ist
ja ein Projekt was wir jetzt schon
begonnen haben wo man Bürger auch
zusammen holt über vielleicht
gesellschaftspolitische Themen
diskutieren lässt und das auch ins
Parlament trägt mache ich bei den
Bürgerinnen direkt mal weiter denn da
gibt es ja durchaus unterschiedliche
Auffassungen ob das ob das sinnvoll ist
auf der einen Seite bezieht man den
Menschen mit ein zu bestimmten Themen
auf der anderen Seite sind wir ja nach
wie vor eine repräsentative Demokratie
wo die gewählten Vertreter des Volkes
quasi die Entscheidungen treffen sollen
ist da nicht ein Zwiespalt
den sehe ich so nicht diesen Zwiespalt
das könnte einer werden aber im Moment
haben wir ja auch ein Parlament wo nicht
alle Berufsgruppen zwangsläufig nie
vertreten sein können deswegen finde ich
die bürgerräte ein gutes Element und ich
will dieses Projekt einfach mehr
anschauen vielleicht kann man es auch in
der ein oder anderen Weise noch
verändern oder verbessern weil wir
manchmal ja auch in unseren Wahlkreisen
mit bestimmten Zielgruppen immer
sprechen und vielleicht auch nicht alle
im Fokus haben und durch bürgerräte
kommen vielleicht Meinung rein die wir
selbst in unseren Wahlkreisen so nicht
wahrnehmen und das wäre mir wichtig dass
wir eben auch die Menschen wahrnehmen
die vielleicht so den Zugang nicht haben
hieße das dann unter Umständen auch eine
engere Verzahnung von der
Ausschussarbeit und mit diesem
bürgerräten oder wie konkret kann man
sie machen ja es könnte zum Beispiel ein
Element sein aber das muss ich noch
prüfen und natürlich viele Gespräche
führen aber der Petitionsausschuss ist
ja zum Beispiel ein Ausschuss der ja
sehr stark Bürgeranliegen bearbeitet und
das könnte ein Element sein wo denn
diese bürgerräte dann letztendlich auch
angedockt werden und das was dort
vielleicht besprochen und auch
angetragen wird dann tatsächlich auch in
die Arbeit vielleicht
dispetitionsausschusses einfließen kann
dazu muss man sich das Element aber
nochmal angucken ob das dann auch dann
tragbar ist und natürlich auch mit den
Fraktionen und Abgeordneten sprechen die
dann im Petitionsausschuss auch arbeiten
das ist ein Punkt wo sie die das
Parlament auch vielleicht noch mal ein
anderes Licht rücken wollen das anderen
Punkt den Sie angesprochen haben auch
schon ist die Sprache in der Politik
auch die Sprache von ich glaube
gesetzesstexen nun lesen ja
Gesetzestexte überwiegend Verwaltung und
nicht die Bürgerinnen und Bürger also
wie wo sehen sie da den Vorteil wenn
sich da was ändert
also zum einen habe ich an mir selber
immer festgestellt wenn man so hier auch
in den Debatten so in seiner
Fachlichkeit drin ist dass man oft
Abkürzungen benutzt oder eine bestimmte
Fachsprache die wir alle kennen die wir
hier damit jeden Tag beschäftigt sind
aber die ZuhörerInnen oder Zuschauer das
zum Teil nicht nicht verstehen Abkürzung
und so das ist das eine und das andere
ist natürlich auch komplexe Sachverhalte
in leichter oder einfacher Sprache auch
weiterhin umzusetzen dass wir das noch
ausbauen das wird dir jetzt schon sehr
gut abgerufen nicht nur vom Menschen mit
Behinderung sondern eben auch von
Menschen die vielleicht einen anderen
Zugang zu komplexen Themen brauchen und
das kann man sicherlich noch ausbauen
ist das ein zentraler Punkt warum sich
die Menschen von der Politik abgewendet
haben oder wo denken Sie woran liegt das
darüber hinaus und wo sehen sie da noch
Möglichkeiten diese Leute wieder
zurückzugewinnen für das Geschäft hier
beispielsweise des Bundestages also mein
es war ja auch ein Appell aber es ging
natürlich auch in einen jetzt neues
Parlament neu gewählt viele neue
Abgeordnete die ihre Wahlkreisarbeit ja
jetzt auch neu gestalten und natürlich
ist es in erster Linie auch die Aufgabe
von Abgeordneten selbst die natürlich im
Land in ihren Wahlkreisen ihre
politische Arbeit zum einen vertreten
aber auch die Probleme mitnehmen dass
die einfach auch Sommer offen sind
vielleicht neue Formate finden Bürger
anzusprechen das ist ein wichtiger
Schritt und wie gesagt die bürgerräte
oder die Öffnung des Parlaments mehr
Transparenz wie Dinge ablaufen aber auch
die Offenheit Argumente zu hören weil
ich schon spüre auch durch viele
Demonstrationen und auch durch die
Pandemie jetzt das so ein Stück weit die
Gesellschaft sich auch spaltet und das
ist eine große Gefahr für unsere
Demokratie wie wir sie kennen und auch
für die parlamentarische Demokratie und
daran zu arbeiten dass wir da
zusammenzuführen und auch schwierige
Themen anzufassen und zu diskutieren in
offenen Debatten ist ein wichtiges
Element das auch die Menschen draußen
merken wir werden hier auch gehört und
es wird hier wahrgenommen sie haben auch
mehr Respekt für das Parlament
eingefordert also auf der einen Seite
gesagt irgendwie wir müssen uns auch
mehr um die Leute kümmern auf der
anderen Seite erwarten wir aber auch
mehr Respekt gegenüber unserer Arbeit
wie wollen Sie das noch deutlicher
machen oder klarer einfordern also ein
bisschen kommt es ja auch darauf an wie
wie Bürgerinnen und Bürger uns
ansprechen und was mir im Hinterkopf war
als ich das gesagt habe war eben auch
das oft keine sachliche Diskussion mehr
stattfindet sondern ja auch viel Hass
uns Abgeordneten entgegenschlägt und wir
haben Abgeordnete die mittlerweile mit
Personenschutz unterwegs sind weil sie
sehr stark angegriffen und auch unter
Mord rumstehen und ich finde da erwarte
ich einfach Respekt dass man wieder zu
einem zu einem Gespräch zu einem Dialog
zurückführt oder zurückkommt wo man mit
den Bürgerinnen und Bürger auch wieder
auf einer sachlichen Ebene über komplexe
Themen reden kann das hat sich unter
anderem auch am Thema Corona und
Pandemie noch mal manifestiert und auch
noch mal deutlich verstärkt wir haben
jetzt auch gerade wieder eine intensive
Debatte zu dem Thema unter anderem weil
die epidemische Lage nationaler
Tragweite aufgehoben werden soll wie
stehen Sie dazu
also dass diese das Element diese
epidemische Lage war ja der der Grund
für viele die auch Kritik geübt haben
dass das Parlament selber nicht mehr
entscheidet das war ja gefühlt so dass
wir nur noch in Verordnung arbeiten und
eigentlich eher die Regierung dann die
Aufgabe übernimmt die Pandemie zu
bekämpfen deswegen finde ich es schon
richtig dass wir jetzt da wieder
zurückgehen und sagen wir wollen hier im
Parlament die Maßnahmen die wie wir mit
Corona umgehen auch wieder hier im
Parlament entscheiden allerdings gebe
ich zu dass die Kommunikation schwierig
ist wenn man sagt wir verlängern diese
epidemische Lage nicht kann man den
Eindruck haben dass die Pandemie vorbei
ist und das ist sie absolut nicht im
Gegenteil im Moment haben wir sehr stark
steigende Zahlen sehr viele Menschen die
wieder schwer erkranken und deshalb sehe
ich ein dass es kommunikativschwierig
ist aber für mich ist wichtig dass das
Parlament hier wieder entscheidet die
das Parlament muss über die Maßnahmen
diskutieren das muss transparent sein
und hier muss die Entscheidung fallen
vor diesem Hintergrund gibt es jetzt
gerade wieder massive Forderungen von
einzelnen Ministerpräsidenten die sagen
es braucht eine neue Bund-Länder sind
wir wieder an so einem Punkt wie
ungefähr auch schon mal vor einem Jahr
und die Frage ist dann wer entscheidet
eigentlich also die diese diese Runde
oder das Parlament wie wollen sie da
deutlicher machen dass das Parlament
doch das eigentliche sagen hat also dass
wir natürlich den Rahmen am Ende hier
politisch beschließen indem die Länder
handeln können und dass die Länder sich
jetzt zusammensetzen wollen weil es
natürlich auch das Virus wie immer an
Ländergrenzen kein Halt macht trotzdem
gibt es ja Unterschiede in dem in dem
einen Bundesland sind die impfzahlen
sehr sehr hoch in dem anderen eher
weniger und da kann man einfach alle
Maßnahmen nicht über einen Kamm scheren
das ist so deswegen finde ich es
grundsätzlich gut wenn sich die Länder
Chefs und Chefin zusammensetzen aber die
Entscheidung in welchem Rahmen man sich
politisch bewegt bei Einschränkungen bei
Maßnahmen das sollte schon in den
Parlamenten diskutiert und auch
entschieden werden wir machen am Ende
dieses Gesprächs noch mal ein ganz
großen Sprung wie viel Zeit wird ihnen
bleiben für den MSV Duisburg na mal
gucken ich hoffe dass ich noch die
Möglichkeit habe ins Stadion zu gehen
und ja Unterstützung brauchen die
im Moment nicht so gut aus aber es gab
ja schon den ein oder anderen Sieg und
ich hoffe dass wir das beim nächsten
Heimspiel auch wieder fortsetzen können
Frau Bundestagspräsidentin vielen Dank
für das Gespräch vielen Dank für Ihre
Zeit danke
gestern in unserem Gespräch hier und in
wenigen Minuten wird sie ihre erste
reguläre Parlamentssitzung hier leiten
auf der Tagesordnung steht unter anderem
die Änderung des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes was wiederum
viele Änderungen auch an anderen
Gesetzen zur Folge haben wird der
Bundestag wird auch diskutieren über
Strafen für Menschen die Impfpässe
fälschen das Thema Migration ist auf der
Agenda insbesondere vor dem Hintergrund
der Lage an der polnischen Grenze und
über heiz- und Wohnkosten soll auch noch
diskutiert werden im Laufe des Tages und
eine Aktuelle Stunde steht auch noch auf
dem Programm beantragt von den von der
Fraktion cdu/csu und da wird es gehen um
die Klimapolitik und jetzt bekomme ich
das Signal dass sie neue
Bundestagspräsidentin an ihrem Platz ist
und gebe rein
bevor ich die Tagesordnung in die
Tagesordnung einsteige und die
Tagesordnung aufrufe
habe ich folgende Mitteilung die
Fraktion haben sich mehrheitlich darauf
verständigt dass die Sitzungen bis zum
31 Januar
ein
drei-g-konzept gilt das bedeutet
das Zutritt zum Plenarsaal in der
unteren Ebene ausschließlich die
Personen haben die vollständig gegen das
sarskopf zwei Virus geimpft sind von
einer corona-erkrankung genesen oder
aktuell negativ getestet sind der
geimpft genesenen oder getestet Status
ist nach Maßgabe meiner
Allgemeinverfügung zur maskenpflicht und
zur Geltung der 3g-regel vom 8 November
2021 als Zutrittsberechtigung zur
unteren Ebene des Plenarsaals
zur West- und abgeordnetenlobby durch
entsprechende Zertifikate nachzuweisen
geimpfte haben darüber hinaus die
Möglichkeit den Nachweis durch ein auf
ihrem Abgeordneten Ausweis angebrachtes
Hologramm zu erbringen
diejenigen Abgeordneten die einen
solchen Nachweis nicht erbringen oder
trotz Nachweis mit Abstand sitzen
möchten haben die Möglichkeit unter
Wahrung des abstandsgebots auf den
Tribünen an der Sitzung teilzunehmen
Mikrofone sind dort vorhanden auch
Wahlen und namentliche Abstimmung finden
für diese Abgeordneten auf der Tribüne
statt
bitte beachten Sie das weiterhin die
Pflicht zum Tragen einer medizinischen
mund-nasen-bedeckung gilt diese kann am
Sitzplatz am Rednerpult an den
saalmikrofonen abgelegt werden
sofern Sie hier im Plenum einschließlich
der West und der Abgeordneten Lobby
gegen diese zutrittsregeln die
Nachweispflicht die Pflicht zum Tragen
einer medizinischen mund-nasen-bedeckung
sowie das für die Abgeordneten auf den
Tribünenplätzen geltende Abstandsgebot
verstoßen kann dies mit den Mitteln des
parlamentarischen Ordnungsrechts
geahndet werden
wir kommen nun zur Abstimmung über die
Anwendung des 3g-konzeptes bis zum
januar bis zum 31 Januar 2022
wer stimmt dafür
das sind die Fraktionen die Linke SPD
Bündnis 90 Grüne cdu/csu FDP
wer stimmt dagegen
die afd-fraktion gibt es Enthaltungen
das ist nicht der Fall damit ist das
3g-konzept als Teil unserer
parlamentarischen Ordnung beschlossen
nun kommen wir zur Tagesordnung für die
heutige Sitzung konnte zwischen den
Fraktionen keine Tagesordnung vereinbart
werden die Fraktion der AFD hat dem
Vorschlag der anderen Fraktion
widersprochen ich habe daher
den Bundestag mit der vorgeschlagenen
Tagesordnung einberufen nach § 21 Absatz
3 der Geschäftsordnung ist für die
Genehmigung der Tagesordnung ein
plenarbeschluss erforderlich
interfraktionell ist vereinbart worden
zum Tagesordnungspunkt 7 einen Antrag
der Fraktion der AFD zum Thema heiz- und
Stromkosten Anstieg aufzusetzen außerdem
hat die Fraktion der cdu/csu eine
Aktuelle Stunde mit dem Titel
Klimagipfel in Glasgow stockende
Verhandlungen in Berlin Haltung von SPD
Grünen und FDP zur künftigen
Klimapolitik verlangt die nach
Tagesordnungspunkt 8 aufgerufen wird
vor der Abstimmung über die Tagesordnung
wird von der Fraktion der AFD das Wort
zur Geschäftsordnung gewünscht
das Wort hat
der Herr Dr Baumann
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
die Koalitionsgespräche ziehen sich bei
wichtigen Themen ist die Uneinigkeit
groß die Meinungen gehen weit
auseinander schon in der letzten
Sitzungswoche musste ich hier eine
Geschäftsordnungsdebatte führen weil sie
der AFD ihre legitim Anspruch
verweigerten hier im Bundestag den
alterspräsidenten zu stellen denn auf
eines können Sie sich hier immer einigen
meine Damen und Herren die
parlamentarischen Rechte der AFD zu
schleifen
aber schlimmer noch in den vergangenen
Sitzungen werden sie die Vizepräsidenten
des Bundestages neu jede Fraktion hat
laut Geschäftsordnung einen ein
Vizepräsidenten jede bekam auch eine nur
die AFD nicht seit vier Jahren geht das
jetzt so mit all diesen unfairen
Machenschaften kriegen sie uns aber
nicht gleich meine Damen und Herren wir
setzen uns trotzdem durch
aber deshalb lesen Sie sich jetzt etwas
noch perfideres einfallen nun geht es um
den parlamentarischen Kernbereich es
geht um die Redezeiten denn sie die
anderen Fraktionen haben beschlossen
plötzlich die Debatten Zeiten und damit
die Redezeiten zu ändern wir haben ja
Bundestag grundsätzlich zwei Formate für
die Debatten ein kürzeres in dem
ungefähr drei Viertel aller Aussprachen
hier laufen und ein längeres für
besondere Themen für die kürzeren
Debatten haben sie jetzt beschlossen
diese sollen künftig
31 Minuten lang sein wieso 31 das
längere debattenformat setzen die
plötzlich auf komische 67 Minuten hallo
31 und 67 Minuten für Debatten hier im
Deutschen Bundestag warum diese völlig
willkürlichen und Krump Primzahlen wie
kommen sie auf so krumme Dinger ich kann
Ihnen sagen woher das kommt das sind
genau jene minutenzahlen die die AFD
maximal benachteiligen und die anderen
bevorzugen dass der einzige Grund es
gibt keinen anderen meine Damen und
Herren
denn bei diesen Gruppen minutenzahlen
hat die AFD nach den Bundestag hier
üblichen Zellen lag Schepers Verfahren
bei standarddebatten nur noch drei
Minuten Redezeit zu Beginn der
Legislatur hatte unsere Fraktion noch
der letzte Legislatur noch 5 Minuten da
waren es plötzlich nur noch hier jetzt
mit den aktuellen krummen Zahlentricks
nur noch 3 Minuten während andere
Fraktionen hierzugleich optimale
Redezeiten haben mit solchen schlichen
meine Damen und Herren die sind
Hinterzimmer gemeinsam aushecken
beschneiden sie nicht nur die Redezeit
der einzigen konservativen Opposition
hier im Haus sie entwerten auch die
Stimme von Millionen Wähler deren
Anliegen und Interessen die systematisch
klein gehalten und an den randgedrängt
werden sollen übrigens wollen auch die
Kollegen von der CDU heute sich
beschweren über die
geschäftsordnungstricks der neuen
ampelmehrheit hört hört die CDU sei
benachteiligt worden bei der
ausschussbesetzung liebe Kollegen liebe
Kollegen von der CDU ausgerechnet sie
reden sich plötzlich auf über
Benachteiligung vier Jahre lang haben
doch selbst mitgemacht bei der
schlimmsten Benachteiligung einer
Oppositionsfraktion in der Geschichte
des Deutschen Bundestages meine Damen
und Herren
Bernd Baumann oder das der erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
afd-fraktion der unter anderem hier
reklamiert hat die
[Applaus]
Debatten Längen von 31 bzw 67 Minuten
das ist die sogenannte Berliner Stunde
und die war schon immer ein klein wenig
krummes hätte er wissen können
Kollegen ich will mal wieder versuchen
ein Stück Ordnung hier gleich am Anfang
hineinzubringen weil es ist unerträglich
das will ich Ihnen sagen das haben wir
vier Jahre jetzt erlebt wir haben es
vier Jahre jetzt erlebt dass sie sich
hier immer wieder hinstellen als
diejenigen die von den anderen gegängelt
hintergangen hintertrieben werden und
sich als Opfer der Demokratie muss man
dann ja sagen darstellen das ist
mitnichten der Fall meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren
jede jede Fraktion hier in diesem Hause
bekommt wie es ein guter Brauch ist
entsprechend ihrer Größe nach der Wahl
auch eine entsprechende Redezeit das
gilt auch für die AFD und es werden sie
zur Kenntnis nehmen müssen daran wird
sich nichts ändern
sie können sich hier weiter aufplustern
das haben wir vier Jahre schon erlebt
sie können sich hier aufplustern sie
können sich hier hinstellen und immer
wieder behaupten sie sie sind diejenigen
die das Volk hier in Deutschland
vertritt ich sage Ihnen nein sie sind es
nicht sie müssen die Wahlergebnisse auch
zur Kenntnis nehmen das gehört auch dazu
wenn man hier in diesem Parlament
vertreten ist wir haben uns
wir haben uns gemeinsam auf eine
Redezeit verständigt und ich weiß nicht
woher sie das Recht ableiten dass sie
als die fünf stärkste Fraktionen genauso
viel Recht beanspruchen wie die FDP als
viertstärkste Fraktion was die Redezeit
betrifft ich weiß gar nicht woher sie
dieses Recht ableiten aber
aber wir haben es ja bisher immer wieder
erlebt dass sie die Realität verdrängt
dass sie ein Kasperletheater machen aber
ich kann den eins sagen das können Sie
gleich das können Sie gleich in den
ersten Debatten hier zur Kenntnis nehmen
die demokratischen Parteien dieses
Hauses werden es auch in der Zukunft
nicht zulassen dass sie hier ein
Kasperletheater veranstalten das werden
wir vier Jahre lang verhindern wir
wollen für die Menschen die Politik in
diesem Land machen alle demokratisch und
Parteien das werden wir umsetzen wenn
sie da nicht mitmachen müssen sie das
rechtfertigen wir werden es nicht tun
wir bleiben bei der Entscheidung die
Redezeit wird entsprechend der Größe des
deutschen der Fraktionen hier im
deutschen Parlament aufgeteilt ich danke
Ihnen für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank damit kommen wir zur
Feststellung der Tagesordnung der
zweiten Sitzung mit den genannten
Ergänzungen wer stimmt für diese
Tagesordnung das sind die Fraktionen die
Linke sPD Grüne
Union FDP Gegenstimmen
AFD afd-fraktion Enthaltung
keine Enthaltung damit ist die
Tagesordnung so beschlossen ich rufe auf
die Tagesordnung
1a bis 1c Beratung des Antrags der
Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP zur Einsetzung eines
Hauptausschusses eines
Petitionsausschusses sowie eines
Ausschusses für Wahlprüfung Immunität
und Geschäftsordnung
so wie Beratung des Antrages der
Fraktionen der
spd-cdu/csu Bündnis 90 die Grünen FDP
und AFD mit dem Titel Bestimmung des
Verfahrens für die Berechnung der
Stellenanteile der Fraktion
und Beratung des Antrages der Fraktion
der SPD cdu/csu Bündnis 90 die Grünen
FDP und die Linke mit dem Titel Zeitplan
des Deutschen Bundestages für das Jahr
zu dem Antrag der Fraktion SPD Bündnis
90 die Grünen und FDP zur Einsetzung
eines Hauptausschusses eines
Petitionsausschusses sowie eines
Ausschusses für Wahlprüfung Immunität
und Geschäftsordnung liegt liegt ein
Änderungsantrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu
vor für die Aussprache wurden eine drei
Minuten
Runde beschlossen
ich eröffne damit die Aussprache und das
Wort als erstes hat Marianne Schieder
für die SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Bundestag
wird heute die Einsetzung eines
Hauptausschusses beschließen das ist
geübt die Praxis bereits 2013 und 2017
hat der Bundestag direkt nach der Wahl
einen solchen Hauptausschuss eingesetzt
der Hauptausschuss soll den Zeitraum bis
zur Konstituierung der ständigen
Ausschüsse überbrücken er kann Vorlagen
beraten die ihm vom Plenum überwiesen
werden und er kann Beschlussempfehlungen
für das Plenum erarbeiten damit sichert
der Bundestag in einer Übergangsphase
seine Handlungsfähigkeit es sollen
diesem Ausschuss 31 Mitglieder angehören
und natürlich kommen dazu auch 31
stellvertretende Mitglieder die
cdu/csu-fraktion möchte nun das nicht 31
sondern 39 Mitglieder in diesen
Ausschuss berufen werden
mit dem Hauptargument das vor vier
Jahren der habdausschuss auch größer
gewesen wäre nämlich 47 Mitglieder
gehabt hätte natürlich wäre das eine
gute Lösung für die Union weil sie damit
drei Mitglieder mehr benennen könnte ich
glaube aber dass 31 Mitglieder für den
Ausschuss für den Hauptausschuss
vollkommen ausreichend sind und möchte
das auch begründen
der Hauptausschuss wird voraussichtlich
nur zweimal reguliert haben und zu dem
zwei Anhörungen durchführen er wird nur
zwei Gesetze zwei Verordnungen und eine
Vorlage beraten und dafür meine ich doch
sollten 31 Mitglieder ausreichen zumal
ist ja auch wie von mir schon erwähnt 31
stellvertretende Mitglieder gibt der
Hauptausschuss wird zudem nur kurz
bestehen das war 2017 auch anders weil
aufgrund der schwierigen
Regierungsbildung damals dieser
Hauptausschuss für mehr als zwei Monate
eingesetzt war wir wollen allerdings
schon bereits Mitte Dezember die
regulären Ausschüsse einsetzen und mit
der Einsetzung mit der Konstituierung
der ständigen Ausschüsse ist ja der
Hauptausschuss automatisch aufgelöst
sollte es dann auch irgendwelche
unerledigten Vorlagen geben werden die
sofort an die zuständigen Ausschüsse
überwiesen und ich sichere zu liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
von der Union sollte es wieder erwarten
und das ist wirklich ein sehr
unwahrscheinlicher Fall mit der
Regierungsbildung doch länger dauern und
der Beratungsbedarf im Hauptausschuss
anwachsen dann können wir jederzeit
beschließen diesen Hauptausschuss zu
vergrößern und dazu wären wir auch
bereits im Moment sehen wir aber
überhaupt keinen Anlass dazu und ich
sage noch einmal ich glaube 31
Mitglieder für diesen Hauptausschuss
sind ausreichend und 31 stellvertretende
Mitglieder dazu ganz ganz bestimmt
deswegen bitte ich und Zustimmung für
unseren Antrag herzlichen Dank
Marianne Schieder war das für die
SPD-Fraktion die begründet hat warum aus
der Sicht von SPD GRÜNEN und
fdp31 Mitglieder in dem Hauptausschuss
der demnächst jede Menge
parlamentarische Arbeit jenseits des
Plenums zu erledigen muss ausreichen die
Unionsfraktion möchte 39 Mitglieder in
diesem Ausschuss haben und das begründet
jetzt Michael große Brömer der erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
Unionsfraktion sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen liebe Frau Schieder was mich ja
besonders gefreut hat ist der Hinweis
sie sind
konnten sie mir nicht verstehen doch was
mich besonders gefreut hat war der
Hinweis es läuft alles gut bei den
Koalitionsverhandlungen als ich noch die
Kollegin baerbock vor kurzem gehört habe
die NGOs werden aufgefordert ein
bisschen Druck zu machen auf SPD und FDP
hatte ich gedacht es stockt etwas aber
wenn das gut läuft alles bestens
ich will eins vorweg sagen dieser
Hauptausschuss ist ein bewährtes Mittel
zu Beginn einer Wahlperiode wir haben
ihn als Union
2013/2017 selbst genutzt wir haben uns
den sogar ausgedacht insofern hielten
das damals manche Teile der
Ampelkoalition für verfassungswidrig so
einen Ausschuss einzusetzen man sieht
man muss nur im Moment und lange genug
abwarten dann sieht man dass meiste was
sich die Union ausgedacht hat ist doch
letztlich gut und richtig und nutzt wir
stimmen
dem der Einsetzung eines
Hauptausschusses
absolut zu was wir ablehnen ist
allerdings ein Hauptausschuss in
schmalspurgröße weil der Ampel ihre
koalitionskoalitionszeitplan wichtiger
ist als seriöse Parlamentsarbeit der
Ausschuss ersetzt alle Fachausschüsse
wir weiß ja auch jeder das hat die
Kollegin Schieder auch richtig
verfassungsrechtliche rechtliche
gesetzliche Aufgaben des
europaausschusses des Auswärtigen
Ausschusses des Verteidigungsausschusses
des Haushaltsausschusses laut Presse
laut Presse daran halte ich mich
bereiten derzeit über 200 Frauen und
Männer den Links gelben
Koalitionsvertrag vor und wenn dieser
wichtige Hauptausschuss jetzt von 31 auf
39 Personen erweitert werden soll dann
haben sie nicht ausreichend Personal
also das können wir nicht so ganz
verstehen und im übrigen ist es ja so
unsere Koalition hat noch drei Personen
weniger als bei Ihnen den den Vertrag
vorbereiten nämlich 197 und nach ihrer
Planung sollen davon dann acht Personen
tatsächlich ordentliche Mitglieder im
Hauptausschuss werden mit den Aufgaben
die geschildert wurden da weiß ich nicht
wo die breite fachpolitische Basis ist
die Sie im Zweifel auch von diesem
Ausschuss erwarten das ist glaube ich
nicht die richtige Art mit uns umzugehen
besonders beachtlich bei den kleinen
ampelichtern FDP und Grünen ist ja auch
dass sie in der vergangenen
Legislaturperiode in unzähligen reden
Krokodilstränen vergossen haben weil es
bei der politischen und
parlamentarischen Arbeit nicht immer
darum geht Minderheiten zu
berücksichtigen naja jetzt lehnen sie
konsequent jeden kleinen Wunsch es geht
um acht Personen acht Personen jeden
kleinen Wunsch der Minderheit ab naja
ich will jetzt nicht wieder von Arroganz
der Macht sprechen wahrscheinlich ändern
sie auch noch eine Sitzordnung in diesem
Bundestag weil es eben nicht passt wo
Sie sitzen das sind die wahren Probleme
dieses Landes wirklich
sechs Leute zu wenig im Hauptausschuss
und sie sitzen an der falschen Stelle
fangen Sie mit der seriösen
parlamentarischen Arbeit an ich bin
dafür wir setzen den Hauptausschuss ein
aber wir lachen wir lassen ihn auch
arbeitsfähig werden durch unseren
Änderungsantrag stimmen sie ihnen zu
acht Personen mehr kann dieser Ausschuss
nicht nur vertragen es ist gut wenn er
acht Personen mehr hätte vielen Dank für
die Aufmerksamkeit
na ja
für die nächste Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen spricht Britta Hasselmann
und auch Britta Hasselmann ist erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin
[Applaus]
eines Hauptausschusses sowas muss man
sich gut überlegen wenn es eine
Notwendigkeit gibt vor einer
Regierungsbildung muss man es machen
auch das ist ein Prozess den haben wir
natürlich jetzt auch hier als mögliche
neue Konstellation Ampel zu vollziehen
denn es werden wichtige Entscheidungen
zu treffen sein bevor ein Bündnis der
Ampel abgeschlossen werden kann das weiß
jede und jeder hier im Haus und das weiß
auch jede und jeder in der
Öffentlichkeit die Fragen zum
Infektionsschutzgesetz werden gleich
beraten und die machen doch deutlich
dass es dazu einen Ausschuss braucht der
berät und dass man Ausschüsse nicht
komplett einsetzt bevor eine Regierung
steht hat ja Michael große-brömer gerade
erläutert das war die Praxis in den
letzten 16 Jahren
und überhaupt hier im Parlament und
deshalb Michael große-brömer ich
verstehe das an eine neue Rolle muss man
sich gewöhnen sagt Britta Hasselmann für
ihre Fraktion für ihre Fraktion und sagt
irgendwann sicher auch die cdu/csu für
sich
okay jetzt wirklich den Skandal nicht
der hier aufgemacht wird und deshalb
rate ich bei aller Frage der
Rollenfindung das gilt für uns demnächst
in der Regierung das gilt für Sie in der
Opposition
sollten wir doch das was schwierig und
von großer Tragweite ist
so benennen aber hier an dieser Stelle
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus der
Tatsache dass man acht plus acht
16 Möglichkeiten hat Sitze zu besetzen
auf möglicherweise
zwei Tagungen eines Ausschusses darauf
reduzieren wir jetzt mal den angeblichen
Skandal und den kann niemand entdecken
ja sie haben acht Möglichkeiten
sie können acht Mitglieder ordentlich
benennen die anderen acht können sogar
in den Ausschuss kommen es können sogar
alle in den Ausschuss kommen das ist
nämlich die Rechtslage alle können
zuhören und dem Ausschuss anwesend sein
und es könnten 16 von ihnen rotierend
auch beraten wenn es zu
unterschiedlichen themenberatungen gibt
deshalb seien Sie doch bitte so ehrlich
und sagen sich selbst Leute wir haben 16
besetzungsmöglichkeiten für einen
Ausschuss der zweimal Takt wir können
dort alles abdecken für mögliche
Gesetzentwürfe die diesen Ausschuss
erreichen das sind vielleicht zwei oder
drei und dann lassen wir alle zusammen
die Kirche mal im Dorf und befassen uns
mit inhaltlichen Themen in diesem
Ausschnitt
sagt Britta Hasselmann die erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen zu einem
Antrag der Unionsfraktion den
Hauptausschuss statt mit 31 doch besser
mit 39 Mitgliedern zu besetzen Einsatz
vielleicht noch zu diesem Hauptausschuss
er ist alt ein übergangsausschuss in der
Zeit bis es oder für die Zeit bis ist
reguläre Ausschüsse gibt das wiederum
hängt natürlich dann davon ab welche
Ministerium wenn hier Ministerien es
geben wird und in dieser Übergangszeit
regelt der Hauptausschuss bzw befasst
sich der Hauptausschuss mit Vorlagen und
gibt dem Plenum auch
Beschlussempfehlungen Stefan Brandner
ist am Pult für die afd-fraktion Stunden
zu früh ist drei Anträge haben wir heute
hier zu verhandeln einen guten einen der
geht so und einen der
erschlichtergreifend eine Frechheit
darstellt der vorgelegt wurde der erste
gute natürlich mitgetragen von der
afd-fraktion also auch für die
Öffentlichkeit wir haben
gemeinsam alle Bundestagsfraktionen
einen Antrag eingebracht da geht das um
das
Berechnungsverfahren für die stellen
wenn das Frau Merkel mitbekommt wird der
Antrag wahrscheinlich am Ende dann für
null nicht ich erklärt gleichwohl zeigen
wir wir reichen Ihnen die Hand wir
arbeiten mit Ihnen zusammen wenn es
vernünftig ist und vernünftig ist nur
dieser Antrag das tut mir leid hier so
zu sagen zweiter Antrag der geht so es
wurde schon ausgeführt dass die
Einsetzung von Hauptausschuss
Petitionsausschuss und
Wahlprüfungsausschuss angeht muss sein
ob die größten so sein müssen das sehen
wir wie die CDU weshalb mit dem
Änderungsantrag der CDU zustimmen werden
31 Personen ist genau wer die Schwelle
um die AFD klein zu halten also wird
gleich wieder das Berechnungsverfahren
was wir gemeinsam beschließen werden
missbraucht und gegen die AFD in
Position gebracht das finden wir nicht
gut aber damit kann man leben soll er
nur eine kurze Zeit sein wir sind
gespannt wann ihre
Koalitionsverhandlungen zum Abschluss
führen der dritte Antrag schließlich
meine Damen und Herren der greifend eine
Frechheit jährlich grüßt das Murmeltier
es geht mal wieder um die Terminplanung
Deutschen Bundestages 2022 wieder die
Faulheit in Personen die Altparteien die
hier sitzen nur 21 von 52 Wochen das
sind 40 Prozent sind als Sitzungswochen
vorgesehen vorgesehen sind lediglich
drei Sitzungswochen bis Ende Februar in
zwei Monaten drei Sitzungswochen wir
haben opulente karnevalspausen wieder
vorgesehen in als Reminiszenz an die
untergegangene Bonner Republik oder die
gewechselte Bonner Republik zwei Monate
Sommerpause wollen sie machen einen
Monat Winterpause wie von der AFD beißen
auf Granit auch nur eine einzige
Sitzungswoche mehr durchzusetzen meine
Damen und Herren wir sagen Arbeiten für
Deutschland nicht faulenzen für
Deutschland deshalb folgen Sie uns seien
Sie mit uns einer Meinung wir brauchen
mehr Sitzungswochen in Berlin und eine
einzige sollte doch wohl drin sein wobei
die Leute die Menschen draußen ja wissen
müssen eine Sitzungswoche hört sich
jetzt an von Montag bis Sonntag nee eine
Sitzungswoche ist zurzeit ein Tag hier
im Plenum also die Sitzungswochen kann
man auch noch ausdehnen und beschweren
sie sich am Ende wieder nicht wenn die
Sitzungen unseres Bundestages bis in die
Nachtstunden gehen wenn Sie sich lieber
in die karnevalsferien oder die
Sommerferien zurückziehen wir sagen
Arbeiten für Deutschland Deutschland
steht vor extremen Herausforderungen wir
haben explodierende Sprit und
Energiepreise wir haben eine galoppiere
die Inflation wir haben einen weiteren
Massen Ansturm Masseneinwanderung an der
Ostgrenze wir haben kollabierende
Sozialsysteme wir haben gefährdete
Energieversorgung das alles beschäftigt
die Leute draußen und sie beschäftigen
sich mit karnevalspausen Skiferien und
Sommerpausen das ist ein Affront dem
Wähler gegenüber meine Damen und Herren
deshalb nicht Pause machen für
Deutschland arbeiten für Deutschland
Sitzungswochen für Deutschland dafür
stehen wir von der Alternative für
Deutschland wir sind ein
arbeitsparlament und kein
teilzeitparlament also verhalten sich
auch so und stimmen Sie unseren
Anregungen zu mehr Sitzungswochen
durchzuführen vielen Dank
Stefan Brandner für die afd-fraktion
reklamiert die Anzahl der Sitzungswochen
des Parlaments auch im nächsten Jahr
Abgeordnete anderer Fraktionen beklagen
hingegen die Präsenz von
afd-abgeordneten in den Ausschüssen
zumindest ist das in den vergangenen
vier Jahren häufiger mal benannt worden
Bettina stark Watzinger ist
Parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin der
FDP FDP-Fraktion verloren und tritt
jetzt ans Pult TV Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr Brantner
interessant dass sie in nicht
Sitzungswochen nicht arbeiten wir tun
das
ich errate ihnen tun sie das auch dann
tun sie unter dem Land einen Gefallen
am 6
am 26 September haben die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger den Bundestag gewählt sie
haben zu Recht die Erwartung dass jetzt
zügig eine Bundesregierung gebildet wird
die drei Partner die zusammensitzen
gehen ernsthaft und zügig mit dieser
Situation um lieber Herr krosse-brömer
das unterschreibt unterscheidet sich
erfreulich von 2017 und deswegen werden
wir in Kürze eine Regierung bilden
aber aber die Sorgen und Nöte der
Menschen machen natürlich nicht halt sie
stehen nicht still und deswegen ist es
richtig dass wir heute den im
Grundgesetz verankerten
Petitionsausschuss einsetzen die
Menschen dürfen sich an uns wenden an
ihre Volksvertreter die Demokratie macht
keine Pause es ist gut dass wir heute
arbeitsfähig werden
jetzt haben sie schon viel gesprochen
über den Hauptausschuss
Geschäftsordnungsausschuss bei
Prüfungsausschuss
der Hauptausschuss soll zweimal Tagen er
hat eine ganz bestimmte Tagesordnung und
er ist wie schon gesagt wurde mit 31
Mitgliedern besetzt mit 31
Stellvertretern
62 Vertreter hier aus diesem Haus SPD 9
Union 8 bündnisgrüne 5 FDP 4 AFD 3 und
Linke 2 die Union kann mit 16
Vertreterinnen und Vertreter die
jederzeit ausgewechselt werden sie
können Ihre ganze Fraktion ein- und
auswechseln wir haben das Heft des
Handelns in der Hand auch diesen
Ausschuss noch mal zu verändern und
deswegen gebe ich der Union den Rat mein
Empfinden ist dass die Menschen in
diesem Land sich nicht damit
beschäftigen wollen dass wir
untereinander für ränkespielchen treiben
sie wollen nicht dass wir uns mit uns
beschäftigen sie wollen dass wir uns mit
dem Land beschäftigen und da sollten wir
heute anfangen wir sollten Lösungen
finden ich würde mich freuen wenn Sie
das auch tun
und vielleicht zum Abschluss weil sie ja
gesagt haben wie schlecht sie behandelt
werden
2017 haben sie keiner Oppositionspartei
eine Aktuelle Stunde zu belassen wir
geben Ihnen jede Bühne diese aktuelle
Stunde hier heute zu haben damit sie als
Opposition sich äußern können und
deswegen würde ich sagen wer fair
miteinander umgeht kann auch fair
hinterher erwarten dass er so behandelt
wird danke schön
Bettina stark Watzinger Parlamentarische
Geschäftsführerin in der FDP-Fraktion
war das und der letzte Redner in dieser
Debatte müsste sein also es müsste jetzt
der letzte Redner sein sowas gemeint Jan
Korte für die Linksfraktion auch er ist
erster
parlamentarischer Geschäftsführer
liebe Kolleginnen also die aktuellen
Stunden die Teilen nicht sie zu wer hier
wann was machen darf sondern es ist ein
parlamentarisches Verfahren nach der
Größe der Fraktion ich möchte folgende
Anmerkung machen sie haben gewisse
Widersprüche also wenn ich hier die
Rednerinnen und Redner der Ampel mir so
anhören ja also das ist ja hier so eine
Start-up Truppe irgendwie will ich dazu
folgende Anmerkung machen wenn sie
wirklich sagen wenn sie wirklich sagen
es ist alles egal ob 31 der Tag eh nur
zweimal sind besonders wichtig dann
fällt ihm doch wohl auch kein Zacken aus
der Krone wenn Sie einfach mehr
einsetzen das ist eine absolut
Widerspruch was sie erzählt das sind
wirklich kleinkariert besonders leicht
ich möchte folgende Anmerkung machen
also erstens Liebe designierte Ampel
Kumpels ich will ja schon noch mal eine
Anmerkung Mann ich bin schon sehr
überrascht darüber dass sie so sicher
sind dass Sie an Nikolaus oder was weiß
ich von der stattfinden soll hier ein
neuer Bundeskanzler von ihm gewählt
werden sollte also da bin ich mir nicht
sicher weil ich habe jetzt ja
mitbekommen in der Presse dass zum
Beispiel Bündnis 90 die Grünen gerade
aufgefallen ist dass sie überhaupt noch
gar nicht vernünftiges durchgesetzt
haben also nicht sondern ist die FDP
diktiert deswegen ist das doch gar nicht
sicher dass Sie dass man ja ist ja
einfach die Sachlage also deswegen
können wir da nicht sicher sein meine
Fraktion sagt folgendes ich halte den
Hauptausschuss für ein durchaus
diskussionsfügiges Instrument allerdings
kann es grundsätzlich nur eine kurze
Übergangslösung sein wenn sie bis
Dezember nicht hier ihre Koalition
zusammengezimmert haben dann müssen
sofort im Dezember sämtliche Ausschüsse
eingesetzt werden um das hier in aller
Klarheit einmal festzustellen in aller
Klarheit so muss das laufen
ich möchte zum zweiten anmerken wir
sollten vielleicht interfraktionell
vielleicht könnten wir das ja auch im
Ältestenrat oder so Frau Präsidenten mal
ansprechen Angesicht der Situation
darüber nachdenken ob er nicht jetzt
kurzfristig interfraktionell sich darauf
verständigt den Gesundheitsausschuss
sofort einzusetzen ich glaube das würde
Sinn machen auch als Zeichen an die
Bevölkerung dass hier nicht alle hier
rumkommen wie die Bundesregierung jetzt
möchte ich zum dritten etwas zu dem
Änderungsantrag der cdu/csu sagt also
die Linke entscheidet hier grundsätzlich
immer nach sacherwägung ja wieso ja
wieso ja Micha Micha große brühmer ja
pass auf ich kann kann das sagen also
wir finden den Antrag in Ordnung wir
werden immer zustimmen weil das ist eine
Sache wenn euch will auch begründen
warum warum wird er ganz objektiv sind
egal ob 31 oder 8 mehr oder sogar zehn
mehr DIE LINKE hat immer zwei so also
deswegen sind davon gar nicht betroffen
also deswegen gucken wir uns das an denn
ich finde schon in der Tat ja ich will
das hier klar sagen ich finde in der Tat
dass die beiden demokratischen
Oppositionsfraktionen da müssen noch ein
bisschen lernen wie man dazu macht dass
die beiden demokratischen
Oppositionsfraktionen sich hier in
solchen Fragen unterstützen müssen und
ich finde es ist wirklich in der Tat
kein Problem nur weil von ihnen da hier
zwei 300 Leute in irgendeinen
verhandlungsgruppen rumrennen kann es ja
nicht sein dass dies Parlament hier
nicht vernünftig arbeiten kann und
deswegen finde ich das überhaupt kein
Problem warum soll die cdu/csu da nicht
ein paar mehr Leute drin haben also ich
verstehe das überhaupt nicht und
deswegen aus der konstruktiv kritische
Zusammenarbeit in der Opposition da
könnt ihr noch viel von uns lernen
sagt Jan Korte der erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
Linksfraktion in dieser Debatte in der
es um die Einsetzung aus von Ausschüssen
geht aber auch um die Frage wie groß der
Hauptausschuss sein soll ob er 31 oder
39 Mitglieder haben soll jetzt geht es
in die Abstimmung
90 die Grünen
und ein Titel Einsetzung eines
Hauptausschusses eines
Petitionsausschusses sowie einen eines
Ausschusses für Wahlprüfung Immunität
und Geschäftsordnung
hierzu liegt ein Änderungsantrag der
Fraktion der cdu/csu auf Drucksache 30
vor über den wir jetzt zuerst abstimmen
wer stimmt für diesen Änderungsantrag
das ist die Fraktion Die Linke
cdu/csu und afd-fraktion
wer stimmt dagegen
das ist die SPD-Fraktion Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen die FDP-Fraktion
Enthaltung
keine
damit ist der Änderungsantrag abgelehnt
die Fraktion der cdu/csu hat für den
Fall dass Sie Änderungsantrag keine
Mehrheit findet beantragt über den
Antrag der Fraktion der SPD Bündnis 90
die Grünen und FDP auf Drucksache 26
getrennt abzustimmen und zwar zum einen
über den über die Absätze vier bis acht
da geht es um die Einsetzung des
Hauptausschusses und zum anderen über
den Antrag im übrigen ich rufe zunächst
auf die Absätze vier bis acht Einsetzung
des Hauptausschusses wer stimmt für
diesen Antrag das ist die SPD-Fraktion
Bündnis 90 grün und die FDP-Fraktion wer
stimmt dagegen
die cdu/csu-fraktion
Enthaltung
die afd-fraktion und die Linke
Entschuldigung
die Absätze vier bis acht Einsetzung des
Hauptausschusses sind somit angenommen
ich rufe nun den Antrag auf Drucksache
26 im Übrigen auf wer stimmt dafür
sind die Fraktionen linke SPD Bündnis 90
die Grünen cdu/csu FDP und AFD
dann scheint es keine Gegenstimmen zu
geben ich frage aber trotzdem Enthaltung
damit ist der Antrag auf Drucksache 26
im übrigen
einstimmig angenommen damit sind der
Hauptausschuss der Petitionsausschuss
sowie der Ausschuss für Wahlprüfung
Immunität und Geschäftsordnung
eingesetzt
ich komme nun zur Abstimmung über den
Antrag der Fraktionen der SPD CDU
cdu/csu-fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
FDP und AFD auf Drucksache 37 mit dem
Titel Bestimmung des Verfahrens für die
Berechnung der Stellenanteile der
Fraktionen wer stimmt für diesen Antrag
das ist die SPD-Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen CDU CSU FDP und AFD wer stimmt
dagegen
niemand wer enthält sich die Fraktion
DIE LINKE damit ist der Antrag
angenommen
ich komme zur Abstimmung über den Antrag
der Fraktion der SPD cdu/csu Bündnis 90
die Grünen FDP und die Linke auf
Drucksache 31 mit dem Titel Zeitplan des
Deutschen Bundestages für das Jahr 2022
wer stimmt für diesen Antrag
das sind die Fraktionen die Linke SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen cdu/csu FDP wer
stimmt dagegen
die afd-fraktion Enthaltung
keine damit ist der Antrag angenommen
ich rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 2
Wahl der Mitglieder des
wahlprüfungsausschusses gemäß Paragraph
3 Absatz 2
des wahlprüfungsgesetzes die Wahl
erfolgt mittels Handzeichen
dazu liegen Wahlvorschläge aller
Fraktionen auf Drucksache 22 vor wer
stimmt für diese Wahlvorschläge
das kürzt sich jetzt mal ab das ist das
gesamte Haus gibt es Gegenstimmen
Enthaltungen
die Wahlvorschläge sind damit so
angenommen
jetzt rufe ich auf die
tagungsordnungspunkte 3a und 3b erste
Beratung des von den Fraktionen der SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur Änderung
des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes und weiterer
Gesetze anlässlich der Aufhebung der
Feststellung der epidemischen Lage von
nationaler Tragweite sowie erste
Beratung des von der Fraktion der
cdu/csu eingebrachten Gesetzentwurfs zur
Verbesserung des Schutzes vor
impfpassfälschungen für die Aussprache
wurden 67 Minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne damit die Aussprache und als
erstes hat das Wort der Bundesminister
Olaf Scholz für die Bundesregierung
sehr geehrte sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren
das Virus ist noch unter uns und bedroht
die Gesundheit der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger
und deshalb ist es ganz ganz wichtig
dass wir alle Maßnahmen ergreifen um
sicher zu sein dass wir die Gesundheit
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger unseres
Landes schützen können
auch wenn die Lage anders ist weil so
viele geimpft sind ist sie noch nicht
gut ganz besonders deshalb weil nicht
genügend Bürgern und Bürger von der
impfmöglichkeit bisher Gebrauch gemacht
haben und deshalb müssen wir weiter
vorsichtig sein
wir müssen vorsichtig sein und bleiben
und zum Beispiel dafür Sorge tragen dass
die maskenpflicht weiter beachtet und
durchgesetzt werden kann das sind
Verkehrsbetrieben sie genutzt wird oder
bei Veranstaltungen das Abstandsregeln
gelten Hygieneregeln impfnachweise
vorgelegt werden müssen all die Dinge
die wir schon kennen sie werden auch
weiter für die nächste Zeit erforderlich
sein und das ist ein Unterschied
zwischen unserem Land und anderen
Ländern die sich entschieden haben ganz
auf solche Vorsichtsregeln zu verzichten
wir halten sie weiter für erforderlich
und wir müssen auch darüber hinaus viele
viele weitere Maßnahmen ergreifen die
notwendig sind damit wir durch diesen
Winter kommen wir müssen gewissermaßen
unser Land winterfest machen
deshalb bin ich über einige dieser Dinge
und Maßnahmen sprechen die jetzt
erforderlich sind über die in diesem
Gesetzespaket zu entscheiden sein wird
und auch über die Maßnahmen die darum
herum auf den Weg gebracht werden und im
Rahmen der Gesetzesberatung noch dazu
kommen werden das allererste und
wichtigste ist wir dürfen nicht
nachlassen bei dem Versuch möglichst
viele Bürgern und Bürger zu impfen es
haben sich noch nicht alle überzeugt
dass das für sie richtig ist und wir
sollten eine große gemeinsame Kampagne
starten dass die Bürgern und Bürger von
dieser impfmöglichkeit gebraucht machen
die Hausärzte
die mobilen Angebote sind da und wir
brauchen wieder mehr Impfzentren wir
müssen dafür Sorge tragen dass sie
wieder eröffnet werden und wir sollten
auch gemeinsam dafür Sorge tragen dass
die eröffneten Impfzentren auch
gemeinsam auch mit Mitteln des
bundesfinanziert werden
und wir brauchen sie auch weil wir
natürlich jetzt alles dafür tun müssen
dass Millionen Bürgern und Bürger eine
Auffrischungsimpfung bekommen dass sie
sich Boostern lassen das Millionen
Bürgern und Bürger die
Auffrischungsimpfung bekommen das ist
die Aufgabe der nächsten Wochen und
Monate
und auch dazu und auch dazu wird es
erforderlich sein dass wir diese
Möglichkeiten haben die Aktivitäten der
Hausärzte die mobilen Angebote und die
Impfzentren und wir sollten das möglich
machen was jetzt in einem gemeinsamen
Schreiben des Bundesgesundheitsministers
und der Ärzteverbände an alle Hausärzte
und Ärzte formuliert worden ist nämlich
dass man nach sechs Monaten eine
Auffrischungsimpfung erhalten kann soll
und wir werden alles dafür tun dass das
auch tatsächlich überall in Deutschland
möglich ist
ganz besonders ist es wichtig dass wir
jetzt dafür Sorge tragen dass die
älteren schnell geimpft werden und die
dritte Impfung bekommen die Booster
Impfung und darum will ich an dieser
Stelle auch die Pflegeheime ansprechen
die so wichtig sind das war nicht zu
ertragen was wir am Anfang der Pandemie
erlebt haben dass so viele Bürgerinnen
und Bürger erkrankt sind die in den
Pflegeheimen gelebt haben dass so viele
gestorben sind und das darf uns in
diesem Winter nicht mehr passieren
deshalb müssen wir alle notwendigen
Maßnahmen ergreifen damit das nicht
geschieht es muss täglich getestet
werden wer dort arbeitet und nicht
geimpft ist und alle Besuchern und
Besucher müssen einen Test bekommen das
ist für die Sicherheit der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger die in den
Pflegeeinrichtungen Leben erforderlich
und natürlich müssen wir auch
sicherstellen dass überall in diesem
Bereichen gebustert wird dass die
Impfung durchgeführt werden das ist
längst vereinbart und es muss jetzt mit
großer Geschwindigkeit geschehen die
Geschwindigkeit muss ihr zunehmen zu dem
was wir bisher haben und deshalb bin ich
sehr froh dass es hier das Vorhaben gibt
dafür zu sorgen dass die Durchsetzung
des boosterns der Auffrischungsimpfung
in den Pflegeheimen
dass wir für jedes einzelne Pflegeheim
wissen wie weit es ist das ist die
Aufgabe die wir jetzt ganz in
Deutschland durchsetzen müssen
wir werden weiter dafür Sorge tragen
dass an den Schulen getestet wird und
wir müssen sicherstellen dass die
Arbeitsplätze sicher sind darum haben
wir Gespräche geführt mit den
Gewerkschaften mit betriebsrät mit
vielen anderen mit Arbeitnehmern und
Arbeitnehmern und mit den Unternehmen
und wir sind sicher wir müssen eine
zusätzliche Vorsichtsmaßnahmen am
Arbeitsplatz treffen deshalb wollen wir
das in Zukunft an Arbeitsplätzen 3g-geld
man muss dort arbeiten wir haben ein
geimpftes genesen oder aber einen Test
haben und das ist eine notwendige
Verbesserung
und auch das muss jetzt geschehen dass
wir die Möglichkeit nutzen die mit dem
neuen Gesetz verbunden sind dort sind
den Ländern alle Kompetenzen eröffnet
damit sie differenziert nach den
einzelnen Bereichen Entscheidung treffen
können über 3g-konzepte für den Zutritt
zu Gaststätten zum Beispiel zu
Veranstaltungen zu Geschäften und allen
möglichen aber eben auch zu 2G und ich
habe das so verstanden dass viele Länder
sich jetzt auf den Weg gemacht haben und
überall bei sich Entscheidungen treffen
dass sie insbesondere bei Gaststätten
und Veranstaltungen bei Kinos und
Theaterbesuchen 2G vorschreiben wollen
ich halte das für einen guten
Fortschritt dass das überall gemacht
wird die Möglichkeiten dafür schaffen
wir jetzt
für all das was jetzt notwendig ist gilt
aber auch eine Sache ganz entschieden es
muss auch umgesetzt werden deshalb ist
es so wichtig dass wir das Monitoring
machen in den Hinblick auf die
Altenpflegeeinrichtungen und Einrichtung
der Eingliederungshilfe aber deshalb ist
es auch wichtig dass wir sicherstellen
dass an den Restaurants in Deutschland
tatsächlich die zutrittskriterien auch
überwacht werden es kann nicht sein dass
wir solche Vorschriften haben und jeder
geht ein Restaurant und merkt dass sie
nicht beachtet wird gilt nicht für alle
aber gilt an vielen Stellen
damit man diesem Weg gehen kann damit
wir Deutschland winterfest machen können
ist es aber auch wichtig dass wir den
Bürgern und Bürgern die
Rahmenbedingungen zur Verfügung stellen
die für sie es gestaltbar machen damit
umzugehen und darum bin ich froh dass
wir gemeinsam uns
vorgearbeitet haben zu der Einsicht dass
es notwendig ist es die Möglichkeit
kostenloser Tests für die Bürger und
Bürger wieder eröffnet wird wir werden
jetzt die Voraussetzung dafür schaffen
dass es kostenlose Tests gibt es die zum
Beispiel in Apotheken oder bei den
Maltesern oder anderen Einrichtungen
verfügbar sind für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in diesem Lande dann sind nämlich
auch 3g-konzepte in den Betrieben und
zwei g-vorschriften möglich und
3g-vorschriften alles das kann man
machen wenn man Tests anbietet herr
Scholz erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage
aus der afd-fraktion nein
und dann glaube ich müssen wir uns
natürlich damit auseinandersetzen
dass das Virus eben nicht weg ist dass
wir all diese Maßnahmen ergreifen müssen
aber es trotzdem dazu kommen wird dass
viele Bürger und Bürger sich infizieren
und ganz besonderen diejenigen die sich
nicht haben schützen lassen und die
nicht geimpft sind wir sind in der
wirklich schwierigen Situation dass wir
genügend Impfstoff haben dass jeder sich
und jeder sich impfen lassen könnte aber
das ist keineswegs alle gemacht haben
bisher und wir wissen was die Konsequenz
sein wird
sehr sehr viele von denen die nicht
geimpft sind werden sich infizieren
und viele von denen die sich infizieren
werden werden krank werden und von
diesen die sich für die krank werden
wenn einige auf den
Intensivstationen unser Krankenhäuser um
ihr Leben Ringen das ist die Situation
die uns bevorsteht und deshalb müssen
wir hier eine Abwägungsentscheidung
treffen eine Abwägungsentscheidung wie
wir trotz der Tatsache dass die
impfangebote nicht wahrgenommen worden
sind und um den Schutz des Lebens dieser
Bürgerinnen und Bürger auch mit allen
unseren Möglichkeiten kümmern
und das hat eine Konsequenz nämlich die
Konsequenz dass wir sagen wir werden den
Krankenhäusern die finanziellen Mittel
geben dass sie jetzt Operationen neu
aufteilen können dass sie Operation
verschieben können die verschiebbar sind
damit sie Platz haben für die
corona-patienten die jetzt behandelt
werden müssen denn bei allem was man
unterschiedlich diskutieren mag übers
impfen wir müssen Schutz für die
Gesundheit aller Bürgerinnen und Bürger
bieten und wir müssen in diesen Schutz
der Krankenhäuser ermöglichen
das ist jetzt das Gesetz des Paket das
wird beraten hier im Deutschen Bundestag
es wird beraten zwischen den Parteien
und ich will ausdrücklich sagen Ich
fände es sehr schön wenn das Partei
übergreifend getragen wird weit über die
Parteien hinaus die künftige Regierung
bilden wollen das ist jedenfalls die
Absicht und ich möchte alle an den Laden
mitzumachen hier in dieser wichtigen
Gesundheitskrise müssen wir über
Parteigrenzen und über Regierung und
Oppositionen hinweg zusammenarbeiten
und wir müssen und werden auch mit den
Ländern sprechen und den Gemeinden über
das was dann zusätzlicher Unterstützung
notwendig ist und wie wir all das was
jetzt hier möglich gemacht wird auch
umsetzen das muss ja in der Wirklichkeit
sich wiederfinden und deshalb wird es
auch die Kanzlerin und ich sind darüber
einig wird es auch in der nächsten Woche
ein Gespräch ganz klassisches Gespräch
zwischen der Bundesregierung und den
Ministerpräsidenten und den
Ministerpräsidenten der Länder geben um
die Umsetzung Schritte genau zu
besprechen die sich aus all dem was hier
auf den Weg gebracht wird ergeben wird
das ist das was wir jetzt brauchen dass
das Land zusammenhält und an einem
Strang zieht in eine Richtung damit wir
diesen Winter überstehen und mein
letzter Wunsch an die Bürgern und Bürger
dies bisher noch nicht gemacht haben
lassen sie sich impfen es ist wichtig
für Ihre Gesundheit und es ist gesichtig
für unser Land schönen Dank
ein impfappell des geschäftsführenden
Bundesfinanzministers der ja hofft in
wenigen Wochen auch Bundeskanzler zu
sein er hat noch mal die
Vorsichtsmaßnahmen beschrieben die
weiter gelten sollen zum Beispiel 3G am
Arbeitsplatz und das bringt uns auch
ganz schnell zu dem Punkt dass auch im
Bundestag hier im Reichstagsgebäude drei
EG gilt und man also entweder nachweisen
muss dass man geimpft ist genesen oder
einen Test beibringt und da sehen wir
noch mal die Tribüne auf der all
diejenigen sitzen die einen dieser
Belege nicht nachweisen wollen wir
liegen glaube ich ganz gut mit der
Feststellung dass es sich hier
überwiegend um afd-abgeordnete handelt
jetzt kommt eine zwischenintervention
aus den Rhein der AFD
gespielt hat eine Zwischenfrage der AFD
die berechtigt ist zuzulassen
meine Frage
meine Frage die sie vielleicht nicht nur
mir sondern auch der Bevölkerung
beantworten sollten ist folgende wir
haben ja nun alle gelernt dass auch
geimpfte Personen eine genauso hohe
Virenlast tragen können wie ungeimpfte
sie haben von der 3g-regelung am
Arbeitsplatz geredet nun erklären Sie
doch mal mir und auch der Bevölkerung
welchen Sinn das macht dass geimpfte
Personen nun nicht getestet werden
müssen denn Sie können ja andere genauso
gut anstecken wie ungeimpfte also ist
doch die Frage warum ist es so dass
nicht entweder alle oder niemand
getestet werden muss das versteht
nämlich in der Bevölkerung wirklich
niemand aber vielleicht können Sie diese
Frage mal beantworten danke
Herr Bundesminister möchten Sie erwidern
gerne auf Ihre Frage antworten erstmal
ist es so dass es wichtig ist dass man
sich impfen lässt weil das dazu beiträgt
dass man geschützt ist vor dem Virus
aber wir wissen dass es ja kein
Raumanzug den wir tragen sondern das ist
etwas was unseren Körper in die Lage
versetzt mit einer lebensbedrohlichen
Gefahr besser umzugehen und dass das der
Fall ist dass das der Fall ist
das sehen wir an den ganz
unterschiedlichen
Krankheitsverläufen derjenigen die
infiziert sehen das sehen wir an der
ganz unterschiedlichen Betroffenheit
viel weniger geimpfte sind betroffen von
der Infektion als diejenigen die sich
nicht haben impfen lassen und deshalb
ist es erstmal so ja es ist wichtig sich
impfen zu lassen und es führt dazu dass
man auch besser mit der Sache umgehen
kann und dass die Virenlast dann auch
typischerweise geringer ist weil der
Körper schnell und zügig mit der
Infektion umgehen kann
aber erstens wer sich hat impfen lassen
und sich trotzdem testen lässt wie die
meisten von uns ununterbrochen weiter
getestet werden macht nichts falsch
und zweitens ich teste mich mehrfach die
Woche und ich mache das auch oft weil
ich zu Veranstaltungen gebeten werde und
alle sagen lassen sich bitte testen
mache ich trotz meiner Impfung und ich
finde das können auch viele andere
machen und selbstverständlich fändig zum
Beispiel dass wenn bei den alten
Pflegeeinrichtungen jemand als Besucher
kommt und wenn er dann getestet sich
testen lässt trotz seiner Impfung dann
ist das keine schlechte Sache also das
sollten wir schon alles mit im Blick
haben
was sie machen
was sie machen ist merkwürdige
Konstruktion die alle immer an der Sache
Vorbeigehen zu fabulieren Konstruktion
die darüber hinwegreden dass das einzige
was dazu beitragen kann dass wir die
Gesundheit dieses Landes und der Bürgern
und Bürger schützen können ist dass sich
möglichst viele impfen lassen und für
jeden Einzelnen ist es auch die beste
Lösung schönen Dank
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Ralf Brinkhaus
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
die Zahlen die uns heute morgen erreicht
haben sind dramatisch über 50.000
Neuinfektionen es ist so dass die
hospitalisierungszahlen steigen es ist
so dass wir die Hilferufe von der
Intensivstation kriegen übrigens nicht
nur von den krankenhausleitern sondern
auch von den Pflegerinnen und Pflegern
die einfach nicht mehr können das muss
an dieser Stelle auch mal gesagt werden
wir haben eine viel zu hohe Todeszeit
sie hat sich gegenüber dem August
verzehnfacht und wir sind in einer
Situation wo viel zu wenig Menschen hier
in diesem Land noch geimpft sind es ist
so dass die drittimpfung ich mag das
nicht über Booster Impfungen zu sprechen
sondern zu drittimpfung dass diese
drittimpfung nicht gut genug organisiert
sind das heißt wir stehen vor einer
riesigen Problemlage wir stehen vor
einer vierten Welle wir sind in einer
vierten Welle und deswegen ist es auch
richtig dass wir das nicht nur einfach
durchlaufen lassen sondern dass wir hier
und heute im Deutschen Bundestag darüber
ernsthaft debattieren das ist dringend
dringend notwendig und Herr Scholz ich
finde es auch richtig dass sie sich
jetzt als wahrscheinlich zukünftiger
Kanzler endlich auch dieser Diskussion
gestellt haben dass sie endlich was
gesagt haben aber ich muss Ihnen eins
konstatieren das war mehr eine
Zustandsbeschreibung als eine kraftvolle
politische Aussage liebe Kollegen
und es ist auch wichtig und es ist auch
gut und richtig dass wir uns die Zeit
dafür nehmen wir haben ja eben einen
Hauptausschuss eingesetzt es ist richtig
dass wir auch eine Anhörung machen das
ist alles gut es ist auch richtig ich
habe es gerade vernommen dass die
Ministerpräsidenten sich jetzt endlich
nächste Woche dann auch mal mit der
Bundesregierung treffen das LAG übrigens
nicht an den
cdu/csu-ministerpräsidenten sondern Herr
Müller sitzt ja auch hier im Plenum es
lag an den spd-ministerpräsidenten und
ich hätte es als respektvoll empfunden
das bevor wir über dieses Gesetz
abstimmen bevor wir über dieses Gesetz
beraten die Ministerpräsidenten sich
zusammengesetzt hätten weil wir dieses
Problem nur zusammen mit Bund und
Ländern lösen können meine Damen und
Herren
aber was nicht gut und richtig ist Herr
Scholz ist
das was sie hier als Gesetzentwurf
eingebracht haben und sie haben eine
Sache konsequent ausgelassen sie haben
nämlich den Menschen in diesem Land
nicht verraten dass es Ihr Wunsch ist
das ist der Wunsch der Ampel ist dass
die epidemische Lage von nationaler
Tragweite die Grundlage die
rechtssichere Grundlage die verlässliche
Grundlage für unsere pandemiepolitik
auslaufen sollen da haben sie kein Wort
darüber verloren und bevor dann jetzt
irgendwelche Zweifel kommen warum wir
diese epidemische Lage brauchen ich
zitiere mal aus dem Gesetz was wir hier
haben den § 5 des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes da heißt es
eine epidemische Lage von nationaler
Tragweite liegt vor wenn eine ernsthafte
Gefahr für die öffentliche Gesundheit in
der gesamten Bundesrepublik Deutschland
besteht weil eine dynamische Ausbreitung
einer bedrohlichen übertragbaren
Krankheit über mehrere Länder in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland droht oder
stattfindet meine Damen und Herren was
ist denn die Situation ist denn hier
jemand der Meinung dass Kurve nicht
übertragbar ist außer die AFD ist
irgendjemand der Meinung dass Covic
nicht bedrohlich ist ist irgendjemand
der Meinung dass wir keine dynamische
Entwicklung
haben ist doch eine
Realitätsverweigerung und deswegen meine
Damen und Herren werden wir uns da auch
für einsetzen das sage ich auch ganz
klar dass diese epidemische Lage dann
auch verlängert wird das einzige
Entschuldigung Herr brinkus erlauben sie
eine Zwischenfrage von Herrn Kubicki von
aus der FDP-Fraktion
so die
die zweite Sache ist und dass wir uns
einfach mal angucken müssen was wird
denn da vorgebracht was wird denn da
gefordert da wird folgendes gefordert in
diesem Gesetzentwurf das erstmal Herr
rahmenlos hier die länderrechte
Geschlecht schlecht werden den Ländern
wird Flexibilität genommen den Länder
werden Handlungsoptionen genommen das
geht doch nicht meine Damen und Herren
wir sind in einer Krise die Länder
müssen die Handlungsoptionen haben um
entsprechend gegen diese corona-krise
auch vorgehen zu können das zweite Punkt
ist und das muss man ja auch sagen Sie
haben ja viele Sachen die wichtig sind
sie sagen gerade Krankenhausfinanzierung
herr Scholz warum haben sie es nicht ins
Gesetz eingebracht das wird jetzt
irgendwo nachgeliefert und ich meine man
kann auch von zukünftigen
Regierungsparteien die in
Koalitionsverhandlungen sind in dieser
Krise erwarten dass man sauber liefert
und ihr ist nicht sauber geliefert
worden meine Damen und Herren
und wenn man das ganze mal bewertet da
muss man sagen es ist dünn was sie da
aufgeschrieben haben es ist wirklich
dünn und es ist kommunikativ auch das
völlig falsche Signal dadurch dass sie
die epidemische Lage von nationaler
Tragweite aufheben sagen sie doch den
Leuten es ist nicht mehr so schlimm es
ist nicht
mehr für den gesamten Katalog haben im
Gegenteil wir müssen
dem wir müssen
noch vorsichtiger sein wir müssen gut
durch diese Krise durchkommen aber das
geht doch nicht wenn ich solche Signale
setze und deswegen
und deswegen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wenn wir jetzt zweigeisig fahren ja wir
sind nur konstruktive Opposition ja und
Herrn Scholz wir haben Interesse daran
weiß im Interesse des Landes ist auch
ein vernünftiges Ergebnis zu kriegen und
wenn Sie nicht bereit sind aber
vielleicht erklärt das gleich noch einer
von den Rednerinnen und Rednern die
epidemische Lage zu verlängern dann
machen sie wenigstens ein vernünftiges
Gesetz und ein vernünftiges Gesetz zu
machen bedeutet dass die Länder mehr
Flexibilität brauchen und nicht mit
einem abschließenden Katalog arbeiten
können denn das wird ihnen die
Handlungsoption für eine konsequente
Krisenbekämpfung dann auch entsprechend
nehmen dann schreiben Sie auch alles in
dieses Gesetz rein was notwendig ist
dann sagen Sie uns was Sie für eine
Vorstellung haben wie zukünftig 2G und
3G
abgearbeitet werden soll dann sagen Sie
uns doch wie sie sich vorstellen dass er
konsequente Schutz am Arbeitsplatz da
sein soll das sind doch die Fragen die
wir uns stellen müssen damit wir eine
konsequente pandemiebekämpfung
hinkriegen und dass wir eine konsequente
pandemiebekämpfung brauchen und sie
haben es angesprochen das sind wir
diesem Land schuldig und das sind wir
insbesondere liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zwei Gruppen in diesem Land
schuldig wir haben viele viele Dinge
richtig gemacht was sie nicht richtig
gemacht haben wir haben im letzten
Dezember und im letzten Januar nicht die
Menschen in den Pflegeheimen schützen
können und deswegen der dringende Appell
alles dafür zu tun auch an die
Länderseite dass das was im Dezember
letzten Jahres und im Januar diesen
Jahres passiert ist nicht noch mal
passiert und wir haben eine zweite ganz
ganz große Schuld das ist die Schuld
gegenüber den jungen Menschen das ist
die Schuld gegenüber den Menschen die in
den jungen Menschen die nicht in die
Kitas gehen konnten die nicht in die
Schulen gehen konnten die nicht
studieren konnten die auch viel
verzichten mussten und deswegen meine
Damen und Herren sind wir es doch diesen
Menschen schuldig dass wir alles dafür
tun dass wir schnell und gut durch diese
vierte Welle kommen und dieses Gesetz
was sie hier vorlegen das trägt nicht
dazu bei und deswegen gibt es da noch
was nachzuarbeiten vielen Dank
Ralf Brinkhaus der Vorsitzende der
Unionsfraktion
rummuniert dass die mutmaßlich
zukünftige Ampelkoalition die
epidemische Lage nationaler trag weiter
aufheben will das sei aus
ordnungspolitischen Gründen falsch aber
auch weil es das falsche Signal an die
Bevölkerung sei angesichts steigender
Infektionszahlen katrin Göring-Eckardt
ist die nächste Rednerin Vorsitzende der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen liebe Herr Brinkhaus
wir haben einen Entwurf vorgelegt
nachdem klar ist dass die epidemische
Lage von nationaler Tragweite auslaufen
wird und wir mussten diesen Entwurf hier
vorlegen weil eben nicht vorbereitet
worden ist von ihnen und der
Vorgängerregierung und vom
Bundesgesundheitsminister der in diesem
Sommer gesagt hat wir können das
Auslaufen der epidemischen Notlage
gewährleisten das ist die Realität
wir haben eine wir haben eine Situation
in der bei weitem nicht genügend
Menschen in diesem Land geimpft sind in
der Tat
wir haben einen Gesundheitsminister der
noch amtiert der immer gesagt hat alle
haben ein Angebot bekommen aber wo war
denn eigentlich das Gespräch mit denen
die dieses Angebot nicht wahrgenommen
haben das müssen wir jetzt nachholen das
wissen wir jetzt Nacharbeiten bis zum
Thema dritte Impfung sie können sich
hier nicht rausstehen aus der
Verantwortung Herr Brinkhaus das ist
schäbig und das ist verantwortungslos
wir haben wirklich
eine dramatische Lage wir haben
ansteckungszahlen die weit über dem
liegen was wir einfach hinnehmen könnten
wir müssen jetzt wir müssen jetzt darauf
reagieren mit Maßnahmen die erstens
wirksam sind und zweitens rechtssicher
sind ich finde es nicht sinnvoll dass
wir uns hier hinstellen und sagen wir
machen mal Maßnahmen und die werden dann
von Gerichten wieder gekippt das führt
zu neuer Verunsicherung die können wir
uns nicht leisten meine Damen und Herren
und wenn Sie heute
wenn Sie heute in die Krankenhäuser
schauen wenn sie in die Pflegeheime
schauen ja auch in die Schulen und Kitas
dann sehen sie dort arbeiten wieder
Menschen oder immer noch Menschen am
Limit das müssen wir ernst nehmen wir
müssen den Krankenhäusern helfen wir
müssen klar sein beim Schutz der
Menschen in den Pflegeheimen wir müssen
auch klar sein dabei das ist eben nicht
wieder die Kinder und Jugendlichen sein
können die zuerst zu Hause bleiben
müssen deswegen eben auch viel mehr
Schutz am Arbeitsplatz übrigens auch
etwas was sie bisher nicht gemacht haben
hätte ich mir sehr gewünscht dass klar
als Kinderarzt
so
und Herr Brinkhaus am 22.10 hat die
Ministerpräsidentin Präsidentin
Konferenz den Deutschen Bundestag
aufgerufen und gebeten ein Gesetz
vorzulegen genau das machen wir jetzt
der nein die Ministerpräsidentin
Konferenz hat gesagt sie brauchen einen
Rahmen und diesen Rahmen legen wir jetzt
hier vor und wir diskutieren ihn das
machen wir nämlich auch anders als in
der Vergangenheit wir sagen
diese Diskussionen gehört hierher und
ins Parlament und das ist nicht in Stein
gemeißelt da muss man nicht einfach dann
hier nur noch die Hand heben sondern das
ist das was wir gemeinsam hier
diskutieren und besprechen mit
Expertinnen und Experten in der Anhörung
mit den Leuten in der Praxis die
Erfahrungen haben natürlich auch mit den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
Ministerpräsidenten Olaf Scholz hat es
angekündigt zu Recht wir müssen ja zu
einer gemeinsamen Haltung zu einer
gemeinsamen ladeeinschätzungen zu
gemeinsamen Handeln kommen und dazu kann
ich sie nur aufrufen und die nicht in
billige parteipolitische Aktionen machen
hat so
wenn ich mir anschaue wenn ich mir
anschaue worum es geht dann sage ich wir
sind solche rechtssicheren wirksamen
Maßnahmen schuldig gerade denen den den
Krankenhäusern Arbeiten in den
Pflegeheimen in den Schulen wir haben
eine Inzidenz bei denen die nicht
geimpft sind die ungefähr 20 mal höher
ist als bei denen die geimpft sind
wir haben eine wir haben eine Situation
wo wir nicht einfach sagen können es ist
schon egal ob jemand geimpft ist das
werden Gerichte nicht zulassen und
deswegen müssen wir alle möglichen
Maßnahmen und wir reden gerne weiter
darüber wie der Katalog erweitert werden
kann über die maskenpflicht über die
Frage was machen wir im ÖPNV über die
Frage wie Grenzen wir Veranstaltungen
ein natürlich brauchen wir 2G das ist
eine der wirksamen Maßnahmen die wir
jetzt machen können natürlich brauchen
wir das alles und wenn sie weitere
Vorschläge haben dann reden wir darüber
sehr sehr gern und ich finde wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass wir auch die
Diskussionen die gerade der Ethikrat und
die Leopoldina uns auf den Tisch gelegt
haben dass sie nämlich die Frage stellen
wie ist es eigentlich mit einer
Impfpflicht in Einrichtungen die für
Pflegende für andere vulnerable Gruppen
da sind ich finde diese Diskussion
können wir uns nicht entziehen wir
müssen zu einem vernünftigen zumindest
kommen aber eine Impfung wirkt natürlich
erst in vielen vielen Wochen und
deswegen brauchen wir jetzt
verlässliche testregimes für alle die in
diese Einrichtung gehen und deswegen ist
es notwendig dass die bürgerinnen-tests
wieder da sind und ich finde es ein
wirklich krasses Versäumnis dass die
abgeschafft worden sind wir könnten
jetzt besser und weiter sein wenn das
nicht der Fall gewesen wäre meine Damen
und Herren
deswegen sage ich Ihnen das was wir das
was wir jetzt tun was wir jetzt rasch
tun müssen was wir in selbstverständlich
mit den Ländern besprechen das ist das
was für Sicherheit in unserem Land sorgt
alle hier machen sich bis auf sie da
ganz rechts alle hier machen sich glaube
ich große Sorgen darum wie die nächsten
Wochen gehen und natürlich hätten wir
uns alle mehr gewünscht wir könnten
irgendwie entspannt aufs Weihnachtsfest
blicken das werden wir nicht tun können
und deswegen mein Aufruf lassen Sie uns
mit den ExpertInnen diskutieren lassen
Sie uns hier im Parlament diskutieren
lassen sie uns aufhören parteipolitisch
hin und her miteinander eine
Auseinandersetzung zu führen auf dem
Rücken derjenigen der jetzt als
Patientin und Patienten auf Intensiv
liegen den Pflegerinnen und Pfleger
lassen Sie uns keine Diskussion führen
auf dem Rücken derjenigen die die
Schwierigkeiten in dieser Pandemie in
dieser Pandemie aushalten müssen
deswegen meine große bitte die Debatte
sollte hier statt
wir sollten dafür sorgen dass die
Menschen in unserem Land geschützt sind
dass die Arbeitsplätze sicher sind dass
die Pflegeheime sicher sind dass die
Kinder dass die Jugendlichen weiter in
Kita und Schule gehen können wir sollten
dafür sorgen dass die Intensivstationen
in unserem Land alle Unterstützung
bekommen dafür dass Sie diese so
wichtige Arbeit auch ausreichend machen
können wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
Lage in der wir sind ernst genommen wird
und das wirksame Maßnahmen ergriffen
werden dafür stehen wir bereit dafür
wollen wir hier in diesem Parlament
diskutieren dafür laden wir die
Ministerpräsidentin die Länder in diesem
Land ein und dazu laden wir auch Sie ein
meine Damen und Herren wir haben die
pandemische Lage übrigens vier mal
hiermit abgestimmt und beim fünften
meine ich jetzt sind sie am Zug zu sagen
ja wir benehmen auch gemeinsam
Verantwortung für dieses Land das ist
das was der Lage angemessen ist
herzlichen Dank
katrin Göring-Eckardt die Vorsitzende
der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen mit
einem Appell gemeinsam und vor allem
auch im Parlament nach Lösungen zu
suchen gegen die Pandemie bzw um die
Pandemie einzudämmen einer der
Ländervertreter ist ja da heute nämlich
Bodo Ramelow der Ministerpräsident von
Thüringen sitzt auf der Bank der des der
Bundesländer nächster Redner ist Marco
Buschmann der erste parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer der FDP-Fraktion die
Fraktion von SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP legen Ihnen heute ein neues
Maßnahmenpaket zur Bekämpfung von Corona
bei es löst ein altes Maßnahmenpaket ab
und der Name dieses alten
Maßnahmenpakets führt immer wieder zu
Missverständnissen manchmal hat man den
Eindruck dass diese Missverständnisse
auch bewusst geschürt werden
manchmal hat man den Eindruck
es wird so getan als ob nur weil das
alte Maßnahmenpaket den Namen
epidemische Notlage von nationaler
Tragweite hält dass wenn man dieses alte
Maßnahmenpaket abläuft irgendjemand
behaupten würde Corona sei vorbei oder
wir würden nicht auch robuste Maßnahmen
die gegen diese Krankheit ergreifen
wollen und ich möchte an dieser Stelle
mal eins sagen wir können hart in der
Sache diskutieren über jedes einzelne
Element aber lügen und Fake News gehören
in den Instrumentenkasten von Diktatoren
und und Populisten und die gehören nicht
in die Debatte zwischen aufrechten
Demokraten meine Damen und Herren
dass das alte Maßnahmenpaket nicht so
bleiben konnte wie es war ist eine Frage
der Wahrhaftigkeit ich will sie daran
erinnern erst zu Beginn des letzten
Monats hat der Bayerische
Verfassungsgerichtshof die
Ausgangssperren gekippt der Bayerische
Verfassungsgerichtshof hat gesagt dass
eine Ausgangssperre selbst zu einem
Zeitpunkt als es noch keinen Impfstoff
in ausreichender Menge gab nicht mehr
Verhältnismäßigkeit war und deshalb wird
er auch heute wieder so urteilen dass
auch heute dieses Instrument nicht mehr
verhältnismäßig wäre wer das ignoriert
ignoriert die Anforderungen unseres
Grundgesetzes und ich finde wir müssen
auch in der Krise unser Grundgesetz
respektieren damit wir das bleiben was
wir sind und was wir sein wollen nehme
ich ein freiheitlicher Rechtsstaat meine
Damen und Herren
und wir legen mit dem neuen
Maßnahmenpaket robuste Maßnahmen für die
Bekämpfung von Corona vor wir
ermöglichen den Ländern auf
rechtssicherer Grundlage all die
physikalischen infektionsbarrieren die
sie brauchen maskenpflicht 3G
abstandspflichten Hygienekonzepte auch
welche die behördlich durchgesetzt
werden können das legen wir auf den
Tisch und wir gehen über das hinaus was
in der Vergangenheit Pflicht war es wird
immer so getan als sei das nur ein Minus
es ist dort ein Minus wo es
verfassungswidrig wäre aber es ist dort
ein mehr wo wir versagt haben und der
Brinkhaus ich gebe Ihnen Recht unser
Land hat versagt beim Schutz der älteren
aber wenn Sie mit dem Finger auf uns
zeigen die wir in den letzten Jahren in
der Konstellation nicht in Verantwortung
war müssen sie immer erkennen dass ihr
Finger an der Hand mit dem Finger auf
den sie uns zeigen drei Finger auf sie
zurückzeigen und das macht an ihren
Beitrag nicht zu einem guten Beitrag in
dieser Debatte
wir werden für 3G sorgen und wir liefern
auch eine Rechtsgrundlage für 2G wir
werden über testpflichten in den alten
und in den Pflegeheimen sprechen und da
hat unser Land versagt es gab
Bundesländer in denen die Toten zu fast
90 Prozent aus den alten und aus den
Pflegeheimen kommen und wer da sagt dass
das Instrumentarium dass wir jetzt
ablösen ein gutes war der verkennt die
Realität der bringt aus und das müssen
sie sich in Stammbuch schreiben lassen
und deshalb liegt zum Schluss
nachdem wir alle Dinge klargestellt
haben noch zwei Anmerkungen machen
erstens ich möchte mich ausdrücklich
beim Bundesminister Scholz dafür
bedanken dass er hier seine Vorstellung
zur pandemie-politik vorstellt denn sie
gehört in den Deutschen Bundestag sie
gehört in die herzdamer der Demokratie
und deshalb war es richtig dass hier zu
tun
und zweitens
möchte ich sagen wenn jetzt ein
Maßnahmenpaket vorliegt in einer der
umstrittensten Fragen unseres Landes dem
sowohl Wolfgang Kubicki wie auch Karl
Lauterbach
das Prädikat erteilen dass man damit die
Pandemie erfolgreich kämpfen kann dann
sollte sich vielleicht der ein oder
andere den Ruck geben dass wenn zwei so
unterschiedlich denkende Leute zu der
übereinstimmenden Beurteilung kommt dass
wir ein geeignetes gutes und
rechtssicheres Paket haben dann sollten
sich auch einige den Ruck geben über
ihren parteipolitischen Schatten zu
springen herzlichen Dank meine Damen und
Herren
Marco Buschmann verteidigt das was die
mutmaßlichen nächste Koalition hier
vorgelegt hat bezüglich der Änderung des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes und weiterer
Gesetzesänderung der nächste Redner ist
Sebastian Münzenmaier aus der
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren man höre und staune
nach dem vorliegenden Gesetzentwurf soll
der deutsche Bundestag feststellen dass
die epidemische Lage von nationaler
Tragweite abgeschafft wird Millionen von
Menschen haben darauf gewartet denn man
hat ihnen versprochen dass mit dem Ende
der epidemischen Lage von nationaler
Tragweite auch die
Freiheitseinschränkung aufgehoben werden
freiheitseinschränkungen die viele
Bürger massiv getroffen haben die
Existenzen vernichtet haben und die zu
unzähligen Kollateralschäden geführt
haben heute könnte also für viele dieser
Menschen ein Tag der Freiheit werden ein
Freedom Day wie ein etliche andere
Länder bereits gefeiert haben aber wenn
man sich ihren Entwurf mal genauer
anschaut stellt man fest sie streichen
zwar die epidemische Lage aber die
Maßnahmen sollen bleiben die können
jetzt ja nun sie fordern das Wort
wörtlich so unabhängig davon getroffen
werden ob eine solche Lage überhaupt
vorliegt und sie setzt im vorliegenden
Gesetzentwurf ja noch einen drauf sie
reden hier zwar munter vom Parlament in
der Diskussion im Parlament aber erstens
die nächste klüngelrunde ist schon
geplant wir haben es gehört der
Ministerpräsidenten Stammtisch soll
wieder zusammentreten und zweitens sie
wollen verstetigen in diesem
Gesetzentwurf das auf die Entscheidung
des Bundestages nicht mehr ankommt und
sie wollen die Beteiligung der
Landesparlamente auch noch aushebeln
damit degradieren sie die Herzkammern
unserer Demokratie erneut zu Statisten
und dieses undemokratische Verhalten
wird von unserer Fraktion abgelehnt
meine Damen und Herren
der vorliegende Gesetzesentwurf und wir
haben es ganz deutlich hier vom
Rednerpult von Herrn Scholz und Frau
Göring-Eckardt gehört er wird zu zwei
Dingen führen zu einer extremen
Ausweitung der 2g-regelung in etlichen
Bundesländern und darauf aufbauen zu
einem weiteren massiven und
unanständigen Druck auf Menschen die
sich aus den unterschiedlichen Gründen
nicht impfen lassen wollen wir als
afd-fraktion wir haben ein anderes ein
freiheitliches Menschenbild im Vergleich
zu Ihnen allen für uns ist die Impfung
eine persönliche Entscheidung eines
jeden Bürgers und diese Entscheidung
muss freiwillig und ohne direkten oder
indirekten Zwang erfolgen
und wundern sie sich denn nicht dass die
Bürger da draußen ihnen schlicht und
ergreifend nichts mehr glauben die STIKO
zieht gerade die Impfempfehlung für
unter 30-Jährige mit dem Impfstoff von
moderner aufgrund von Nebenwirkungen
zurück für einige wohl zu spät meine
Damen und Herren die booster-impfung
oder trittimpfung die von Ihnen auch
heute wieder als Weg aus der Pandemie
propagiert wird die wird von der
Fachwelt immer noch überhaupt nicht für
die Gesamtbevölkerung empfohlen das
schlicht oder greifend Unfug die
einzigen die es empfehlen sind die
selbst ernannten Virologen hier im
Deutschen Bundestag die meinen sie
müssen ja Bevölkerung erklären was für
sie gut und richtig ist
und das aktuellste und unsinnigste
Beispiel ihrer corona-politik der
Widersprüche ist die sogenannte
zweijährige diese Regel ist schlicht und
ergreifend sinnlos denn sämtliche
wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse haben
uns gelehrt dass auch geimpfte und
genesene ansteckend sein können und
diese Menschen geimpfte und genesene
wiegen sich also ohne Test in
geschlossenen Räumen und auf
Großveranstaltungen in vermeintlicher
Sicherheit und stecken andere Personen
an während negativ getestete Menschen
die nachweisen können dass sie nicht
ansteckend sind draußen bleiben müssen
da geht es ihnen nur um impfdruck denn
ginge es ihnen tatsächlich um eine
Maßnahme des Infektionsschutzes dann
müssten sie wenn überhaupt alle
Anwesenden ohne Ansehen des impf- oder
genesenen Status testen meine Damen und
Herren
oder um es mit den Worten des ehemaligen
chefirologen der charité-professor
Krüger zu sagen 2G ist nicht sicherer
aber unfreier und wir als afd-fraktion
wir lehnen auch weiterhin ihre Ideen der
Unfreiheit und des Zwangs ab und stehen
stattdessen für eine Rückkehr zu
Freiheit zu Eigenverantwortung und zu
Vernunft basierter Politik ich danke
Ihnen für Aufmerksamkeit
stellen sie doch eine Zwischenfrage wenn
sie bei Fragen möchten freue mich drauf
nächste Rednerin für die Fraktion DIE
LINKE Susanne ferschel und Susanne
ferschel ist eine der stellvertretenden
Fraktionsvorsitzenden bei den Linken
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen es
geht natürlich heute nicht darum die
Pandemie für beendet zu erklären dass
wir auch angesichts der dramatischen
Infektionszahlen ziemlicher Quatsch es
geht um die Beendigung dieses
juristischen Konstrukts mit dem regieren
Verordnungsermächtigungen möglich ist
und damit muss Schluss sein und das
finden wir auch gut
aber liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
SPD FDP und Grünen sie betreiben schon
auch ein bisschen Symbolpolitik weil
natürlich müssen die Länder weiterhin
Maßnahmen ergreifen und der amtierende
Bundesratspräsident sitzt ja heute auch
hier sie werden Maßnahmen ergreifen
müssen um das Infektionsgeschehen
einzudämmen
die Symbolpolitik darf nun nicht dazu
führen dass man den Menschen was
vorgaukelt und sie Kollege Buschmann sie
haben ja versprochen dass mit dem 20
März alle Maßnahmen beendet sein werden
und seit Monaten wird den Menschen
erzählt wenn ihr dieses und jenes macht
dann ist die Pandemie bald vorbei und
ich glaube die Leute haben einfach den
Kanal voll von diesen leeren
Versprechungen
und deswegen sollten wir uns im
Zweifelsfall alle mal daran halten im
Zweifelsfall mal die Klappe zu halten
es ist die vierte Welle und es ist das
vierte Mal dass die Verantwortlichen
warten bis die Welle über ihnen
zusammenschlägt und verantwortlich ist
sie noch amtierende Bundesregierung der
noch Gesundheitsminister sparen und ich
muss schon sagen es war heute so ein
bisschen absurdes Theater für mich Herr
Scholz ich weiß nicht wann sie in den
letzten Jahren nicht in der
Regierungsverantwortung warum haben Sie
denn die ganzen Dinge nicht gemacht die
sie vorgeschlagen haben und der
Brinkhaus spricht von Schuld ja warum
haben Sie denn das alles nicht gemacht
was jetzt die ganze Zeit hier erzählt
haben es ist ein Versagen in Rheine
gewesen was hier passiert ist
angefangen mit der Abschaffung der
kostenlosen Tests die vierte Welle die
war doch absehbar und auch geimpfte und
genesene können den Virus weitergeben da
muss man doch mehr testen und nicht
weniger also es war doch eine absurde
Entscheidung
oder die zu niedrige Impfquote wo war
denn ihre Impfkampagne mit aufsuchenden
und mit niedrigschwelligen impfangeboten
andere Länder zeigen dass es deutlich
besser geht
und dann die fehlende booster-impfung
für die über 60-Jährigen und die
vulnerablen Gruppen die müssten doch
alle schon ein drittes Mal geimpft sein
die Erfahrungen aus Israel die zeigen
doch dass der Impfschutz nachlässt ja
statt zu reagieren haben sie auch noch
die Impfzentren abgeschafft jetzt kommen
die Hausärzte nicht hinterher mit impfen
das ist wirklich unfassbar
und was was haben Sie eigentlich getan
in all der Zeit um den Pflegenotstand
wenigstens zu lindern wenigstens zu
lindern es stehen jetzt noch weniger
Intensivbetten zur Verfügung als Anfang
des Jahres weil die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen in der Pflege so überlastet
sind dass sie weiterhin aus dem Beruf
flüchten
und ich wünsche an der Stelle den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen im öffentlichen
Dienst in den Ländern die jetzt im
Streik sind viel Durchhaltevermögen und
viel Erfolg denn eure Arbeit ist mehr
wert
Liebe Ampel notwendig sind jetzt zu
fortmaßnahmen die Rückkehr zu den
kostenlosen Tests ist schon beschlossen
das ist auch gut so eine lückenlose
testpflicht unabhängig vom Impfstatus
insbesondere in Pflegeeinrichtungen wir
dürfen die Menschen nicht erneut einen
sperren und auch die Arbeitgeber müssen
beim Arbeitsschutz in die Pflicht
genommen werden auch drei GMX Sinn
machen aber unter Einhaltung der
datenschutzrechtlichen Vorschriften es
kann nicht sein dass der Arbeitgeber den
Impfstatus erträgt da sind wir an der
Seite der Gewerkschaften
und im Übrigen geht selbstverständlich
um impfen impfen impfen aber eines ist
auch klar und damit bin ich dann auch am
Ende wir brauchen Investitionen ins
Gesundheitswesen in Kitas in Schulen in
den öffentlichen Daseinsvorsorge
insgesamt denn eine Gesellschaft die nur
auf Profit getrimmt ist wird immer
pandemieanfällig bleiben vielen Dank
die stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
Linksfraktion susanne ferschel war das
in einer Debatte des Bundestages zum
Infektionsschutzgesetz bzw den
Änderungen dazu und da wird der nächste
Redner Dirk Wiese sein
stellvertretendervorsitzender der
SPD-Fraktion und einer von denen die in
den vergangenen Tagen und Wochen mit
federführend waren für seine Fraktion an
diesem bei diesem Gesetzentwurf
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren ich glaube es
ist ein wichtiges Signal dass hier am
heutigen Tag der Gesetzentwurf der
möglichen zukünftigen ampelkoalitionäre
eingebracht wird ist zeigt mit diesem
Gesetzentwurf dass wir Verantwortung
übernehmen in einer nicht einfachen
Situation dass wir Verantwortung
übernehmen auch über den 25.11 hinaus
vor allem rechtssichere Maßnahmen auf
den Weg zu bringen rechtssichere
Maßnahmen auf den Weg zu bringen die
nicht vor einem Gericht scheitern die
nicht wieder infrage gestellt werden die
nicht von heute auf morgen nachgebessert
werden sondern die den Ländern einen
Instrumentenkasten in die Hand geben auf
diese nicht einfache Situation zu
reagieren zu antworten und diese
Möglichkeit geben wir Ihnen mit diesem
Gesetzentwurf den wir heute auf den Weg
bringen
ich möchte an dieser Stelle auch die
Möglichkeit nutzen einmal denjenigen
Danke zu sagen die jetzt gerade in
dieser schwierigen Situation in den
Krankenhäusern diejenigen pflegen und
sich um die kümmern die schweren
Verläufen ausgesetzt sind diese
Pflegerinnen und Pfleger in den
Krankenhäusern die Ärztinnen und Ärzte
die Leisten seit Beginn dieser Pandemie
eine unglaubliche Arbeit ja es sind
schwierige Arbeitsbedingungen ja es ist
herausfordernd wir wissen dass sie ist
einiges zu tun aber mein großer Respekt
für das was dort wieder täglich
geleistet wird gerade jetzt in der
Situation wo es in einigen
Krankenhäusern auch schwieriger wird
ich kann auch die Sorgen verstehen der
vielen Eltern die unsicher sind momentan
gerade aufgrund der Situation dass die
Schülerinnen und Schüler gerade bis zur
Vollendung des 11 die lebensjahres auch
noch nicht geimpft werden können dass
man sich Gedanken macht dass man Sorgen
macht wenn der tägliche Gang in die
Schule letztendlich auch ansteht aber
auch hier ist es wichtig dass wir als
Ampel gut zukünftige ampelkoalitionäre
Maßnahmen auf den Weg bringen Auflagen
gerade für Gemeinschaftseinrichtungen
auch möglich machen wollen und weiter
möglich machen möglich sein sollen und
ich muss auch ganz klar sagen ich bin
manchmal etwas überrascht dass das ein
oder andere Bundesland in dieser
Situation die einfache Maßnahme die sehr
zielgerichtet ist eine maskenpflicht an
Schulen zu haben vielleicht etwas
vorschnell schon aufgehoben hat also
hier wünschte ich mir gerade diese
Möglichkeiten die es jetzt per Gesetz
gibt und die es zukünftig auch geben
wird auch anzuwenden das sind einfache
Schutzmaßnahmen die können helfen und
die sollte man nicht vorschnell aufheben
ich bin auch Olaf Scholz dankbar dafür
dass er das was wir vorhaben und das wo
es hingehen soll auch hier zuerst im
Deutschen Bundestag heute auch erläutert
hat und Olaf Scholz hat es angesprochen
das Entscheidende ist dass wir bei den
Impfungen Vorankommen dass wir ein Zahn
zulegen dass wir gerade auch mit
Praktikern ins Gespräch kommen was gibt
es eigentlich auch noch für kreative
Lösungen um diejenigen zu erreichen die
noch nicht den Entschluss letztendlich
gefasst haben und darum ist es auch ein
Signal dass wir auch als zukünftige
ampelkreuzionäre ein praktiker-panel auf
den Weg bringen was morgen im Deutschen
Bundestag stattfinden wird wo wir noch
mal die Expertise der vielen einholen
wollen die täglich draußen unterwegs
sind die durch kreative Lösung in
einigen Regionen zu hohen Impfquoten
kommen und das muss noch mal ein Ziel
sein das mit in dieses laufende
Verfahren mit einfließen zu lassen
wir bringen jetzt in diesem Entwurf
zielgerichtete Maßnahmen auf den Weg ja
auch mit Änderungsanträgen eine
verpflichtende testpflicht 3G am
Arbeitsplatz
2g-3g auch in der Ermöglichung für die
Bundesländer und ich will das mal ganz
deutlich sagen es ist ja auch nicht so
dass die Länder nichts gemacht haben in
der letzten Zeit wir hatten eine sehr
wichtige
Gesundheitsministerkonferenz der Länder
die stattgefunden hat wo wichtige
Beschlüsse gefasst worden sind von den
Ländern an die Bundesregierung und diese
werden wir jetzt auch im laufenden
Gesetzgebungsverfahren mit aufnehmen mit
einfließen lassen und hier auch an der
ein oder anderen Stelle wo es notwendig
ist wo es zu mehr Rechtssicherheit führt
auch nachsteuern und das kann ich auch
zu sichern
meine
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr
Brinkhaus ich muss auf das ein oder
andere aber noch einmal ganz kurz
eingehen was sie gerade hier gesagt
haben ich will ja nicht verhehlen dass
es bei der letzten Verlängerung der
epidemischen Lage nicht so gewesen ist
dass sie als Fraktion geschlossen
abgestimmt haben das muss man vielleicht
hier an dem Punkt noch mal erwähnen und
das ist auch innerhalb ihrer Fraktion
über die Frage der epidemischen Lage
auch Debatten gegeben hat was sie aber
heute nicht gemacht haben hier und das
können sie im laufenden Verfahren gerne
noch nachsteuern sie haben gesagt das
müsste möglich gemacht werden das müsste
möglich gemacht haben sie haben kein
konkreten Vorschlag gemacht sagen Sie
uns bitte konkret was halten sie im
Verfahren für zielführend was brauchen
sie noch an konkreten Maßnahmen wir
schauen uns das an nehmen das mit auf
aber ich muss Ihnen schon sagen und das
sage ich auch sehr deutlich ich weiß
manchmal nicht was zwischen an Berlin
und München auf der A9 stattfindet ich
bin Markus Söder dankbar dass er bis zum
26.9 sich täglich geäußert hat das hat
uns geholfen das hat neue Konstellation
mit möglich gemacht aber ganz offen
gesprochen das was Markus Söder seit dem
26.9 macht das ist kein verantwortbares
Handeln eines Ministerpräsident derzeit
gilt die epidemische Lage von nationaler
Tragweite sie gilt noch er könnte
Handeln er tut es nicht er redet viel
aber macht vor Ort nichts nicht mal zwei
gehen seinem eigenen Kabinett vielen
Dank
Dirk Wiese am Ende seiner Rede noch mal
mit Kritik an Bayerns Ministerpräsident
Markus Söder und davor hatte eingeräumt
dass es eine und andere oder der der
eine und andere Punkt bei dem
Gesetzentwurf der mutmaßlich zukünftigen
Ampelkoalition zum
infektionsschutzgesetzen nochmal
präzisiert werden muss das kann
beispielsweise eine Anhörung am
kommenden Montag passieren und jetzt
aber Alexander Dobrindt Vorsitzender der
CSU Landesgruppe sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Herr Scholz sie haben hier gesagt wir
müssen weiter vorsichtig sein dazu
hätten sie heute jede Chance gehabt und
zwar mit einem klaren Bekenntnis dass
sie die epidemische Lage weiter
verlängern wollen die Hospitalisierung
steigt das Infektionsgeschehen
explodiert die dritte Impfung muss erst
an Fahrt gewinnen die Risiken steigen
und sie schrauben den Instrumentenkasten
runter das kann nicht gut gehen herr
Scholz
sie verlassen geradezu das Team Vorsicht
und sie gehen ins Team versuche es mal
das reicht aber nicht für ihre neue
Verantwortung und um dieser entsprechend
nachzukommen gerade im August Herr
Scholz da haben sie sich noch für die
Verlängerung der epidemischen Lage
ausgesprochen heute bei mehr Kranken bei
mehr infizierten bei Mehrbelastung der
Krankenhäuser beenden sie politisch die
epidemische Lage das ist schlichtweg
eine falsche Entscheidung an dieser
Stelle
[Applaus]
sie werden hier
eindrucksvoll für das Impfen aus meiner
Sicht vollkommen zu Recht aber sie geben
komplett andere Signale wenn Sie heute
die epidemische Lage beenden wollen wie
soll das in der Öffentlichkeit
eigentlich ankommen wie wollen Sie
Menschen davon überzeugen sich impfen zu
lassen wenn sie das Signal geben es wird
schon irgendwie werden die epidemische
Lage muss nicht verlängert werden es
kommt schon wieder alles irgendwie in
Ordnung das reicht nicht als Signal um
die Impfbereitschaft zu erhöhen
was sie aber tun
sie werden als Ampel sicher unser
Gesundheitswesen vor eine
Belastungsprobe stellen wir haben jetzt
schon Regionen in Deutschland mit einer
Inzidenz von über 1.000 weiter steigend
die Intensivbetten sind belegt
ja in verschiedensten Regionen in
Deutschland auch in Bayern auch in
Sachsen auch in anderen Ländern wird
genau das Anstehen und beim besten
Willen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich verstehe diese hämischen
Zwischenrufe an dieser Stelle überhaupt
nicht es geht um infizierte es geht um
kranke Menschen es geht um Belastung der
Krankenhäuser es geht um eine Situation
die sich weiter verschärfte da diese
dümmlichen Zwischenrufe können Sie sich
beim besten Willen sparen das zeigt dass
sie viele sind aber die regierungsfähig
meine Damen und Herren
man muss kein Hellseher sein um zu sehen
dass in den nächsten Tagen oder Wochen
ist zu einer Überlastung des
Gesundheitswesen führen kann deswegen
ist es falsch den Instrumentenkasten an
dieser Stelle zu reduzieren es ist
schlichtweg ein Fehler und sehr geehrter
Herr Buschmann ich habe ihre Rede sehr
genau zugehört ich muss sagen auch Ihre
Webseite kann man aktuell nachlesen ich
zitiere daraus eine Überlastung des
Gesundheitssystems sei nicht mehr zu
erwarten was für eine grandiose
Fehleinschätzung
und Herr Buschmann die sagen hier am
Pult gerade vorhin
wir gehen über die bisherigen Maßnahmen
hinaus ich darf Sie aus Ihrer Webseite
aus ihrer Webseite Herr Buschmann
zitieren dort sagen sie aktuell
nachlesbar die Fraktionen wollen daher
den Ländern nur noch befristet
niederschwellige und wenig
eingriffsintensive Maßnahmen bis zum
Frühjahr 2022 ermöglichen sie reduzieren
die Maßnahmen Tier steht die Wahrheit
auf ihrer Webseite und nicht in ihrer
Rede hier im Deutschen Bundestag
Eckert sie haben hier gesagt wir können
es uns jetzt nicht leisten dass
Maßnahmen von Gerichten gekippt werden
sie haben über Rechtssicherheit
gesprochen ich darf Sie an dieser Stelle
fragen was ist rechtssicherer wenn der
Deutsche Bundestag die epidemische Lage
feststellt und weiter verlängert oder ob
sie ein halbherziges Gesetz auf den Weg
bringen meine Damen und Herren
und der Scholz wir haben hier für 2G
geworben sie haben gesagt sie schaffen
jetzt die Maßnahmen die Maßnahmen dafür
gibt es übrigens in der epidemischen
Lage und nicht erst durch ihr Gesetz sie
haben dafür geworben ich kann ihn an der
Stelle einfach nur sagen dann nehmen sie
auch ihre Verantwortung wahr und kommen
Sie mit Ländern und Bund zu einer
gemeinsamen Lösung sie können zwei g in
Deutschland durchsetzen sie haben die
Entscheidung dafür
mitzutreffen sie können Druck machen und
sie können alle Länder mit ins Boot
nehmen dazu gehört aber die Bereitschaft
dass man mit Bund und Ländern über die
aktuelle Lage fair und offen spricht
gemeinsamen Entscheidungen trifft kommen
Sie diese Verantwortung nach sie haben
sie jetzt nehmen Sie sie auch an danke
schön
Alexander Dobrindt Vorsitzender der CSU
Landesgruppe ist höher und erkennbar
schon mal in der Opposition angekommen
heftige Kritik an dem Gesetzentwurf der
zukünftigen Ampel Koalition und hier
geht es weiter mit Maria kleinschmaink
auch ein stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende und auch sie hat an
diesem Gesetzentwurf maßgeblich
mitgearbeitet
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin lieber
Herr Dobrindt ich muss sagen sie haben
sich gerade wirklich verstiegen dieser
werdenden Ampel vorzuwerfen sie würde
das Gesundheitswesen schädigen und
gleichzeitig eine Situation verantworten
zu müssen in Bayern wo sie die neuen
höchst Betroffenen Landkreise bundesweit
Stellen wo sie ernsthaft vor der
Situation stehen dass eine Überlastung
ihrer Krankenhäuser ihrer Investition
Intensivstationen und der Beschäftigten
in diesen
Intensivstationen zu verantworten haben
das ist ihre Verantwortung und es ist
unverschämt an dieser Stelle all
denjenigen die sich hier wirklich
bemühen Lösungen zu finden sowas
vorzuwerfen das ist unverantwortlich und
und auch
auch Herr Brinkhaus ich meine wir haben
in den letzten zwei Jahren versucht
gemeinsam dafür zu sorgen dass wir als
Bundestag Verantwortung übernehmen dass
wir schauen dass wir diese sehr sehr
schwierige Situation tatsächlich
meistern und dass wir dem gerecht werden
was insbesondere all denjenigen die
entweder betroffen sind die Eltern sind
die viel viel haben tragen müssen Kinder
und Jugendliche die viel viel haben
tragen müssen und den vielen
Betroffenen und schwer erkranken oder
auch verstorbenen Menschen im hohen
Alter da haben wir uns um Verantwortung
bemüht und sie haben heute hier eine
Rede gehalten die zeigt dass sie nicht
auf dem Weg einer konstruktiven
Opposition sind mit uns gemeinsam
konstruktiv nach Lösungen suchen sondern
dass sie den billigen und sehr
opportunistischen die Anklage suchen und
nicht mit uns gemeinsam jetzt geht es
darum die EP
idemänner dieser Entwicklung die wir
jetzt sehen irgendwie aufhalten können
sie haben eben gerade nicht die
Maßnahmen vorgelegt die wir jetzt
brauchen und das tun wir mit dem Gesetz
jetzt wir schaffen zusätzliche
Möglichkeiten zu denen die bisher im
Infektionsschutzgesetz vorgesehen waren
wir schaffen den besseren Schutz der
vulnerablen in den Einrichtungen indem
wir oberflächliche testpflichten
festlegen wir schaffen insgesamt einen
besseren Schutz in dem wir insbesondere
auch dafür sorgen dass am Arbeitsplatz
das im Bereich der Arbeitswelt wir
zusätzliche Schutzmöglichkeiten haben
zusätzliche Pflichten des Testens haben
und wir werden dafür sorgen dass wir all
die Maßnahmen die wir jetzt vorgelegt
haben im Anhörungsverfahren nochmal auf
dem Prüfstand stellen schauen ob wir
nachsteuern müssen und wir haben uns als
werdende Koalition versprochen dass wir
nachsteuern immer da wo es notwendig ist
dass wir die notwendigen Maßnahmen
schaffen und für Handlungsfähigkeit
sorgen und insgesamt
zur Verantwortung gehört impfen das
Impfen voranzubringen das ist der
Schlüssel den wir brauchen wir müssen
die ungeimpften Erwachsenen erreichen
dringend wir müssen viel viel schneller
werden bei den boosterimpfungen bei den
Auffrischungsimpfungen damit wir
sicherstellen können dass in den
nächsten Wochen die Intensivstation
nicht volllaufen gerade mit denjenigen
die als ältere den Immunschutz verlieren
das ist das was wir jetzt tun müssen und
gemeinschaftlich müssen wir dafür sorgen
dass alle an einem Strang ziehen sonst
wird es uns nicht gelingen gut durch
diesen Winter zu kommen und wir legen
mit diesem Gesetz viele Maßnahmen vor
mit denen wir weiter nachsteuern können
machen sie mit tragen Sie mit uns eine
offene Diskussion dazu aus was wir tun
müssen was wir anpacken können wir wir
sind gespannt was sie an weiteren
Vorschlägen Einbringen in die Diskussion
wir jedenfalls sind in der offenen
Aktion nehmen alle Anregungen aus den
von aus der Anhörung auf so werden wir
vorgehen und damit werden wir auch eine
bessere Situation schaffen danke
Maria klein schmalk aus der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und ihr wird in
dieser Debatte zum
Infektionsschutzgesetz bzw
dessen Änderung aber auch weiterer
Gesetze die in der Folge der Aufhebung
der epidemischen Lage
nationalertragweite nötig werden folgen
Christine Aschenberg lugnos aus der
FDP-Fraktion Gesundheitspolitikerin
nicht zu sagen eine Änderung des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes ist längst
überfällig denn wir benötigen
Rechtssicherheit in der corona-krise und
dieses Parlament muss daran beteiligt
sein meine Damen und Herren
wir haben uns gemeinsam mit SPD und
Grünen zusammengesetzt um diese Lösungen
zu erarbeiten und diese Lösungen werden
jetzt ja da werden sich die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von der CDU und CSU
verwundert die Augen reiben in einem
geordneten Gesetzgebungsverfahren auf
den Weg gebracht meine Damen und Herren
heute die erste Lesung in einer Woche
die zweite und dritte Lesung es wird
eine Anhörung geben selbstverständlich
mit Verbesserungsvorschlägen egal wo sie
herkommen werden wir offen und
transparent umgehen kurz um meine Damen
und Herren es findet die von uns seit
langer Zeit geforderte
reparlamentarisierung statt und das ist
gut so
meine Damen und Herren das Parlament ist
handlungsfähig selbst in Zeiten einer
lediglich geschäftsführenden Regierung
wir zeigen dass wir in der Lage sind
zügig zu reagieren ja und jetzt geht es
los es kommen natürlich sofort
Vorwürfe der Untätigkeit der
unzureichenden Mittel im
Infektionsschutzgesetz Brinkhaus hat es
gesagt Herr Dobrindt hat es gesagt und
natürlich kommen die lautesten Stimmen
von einem Vorsitzenden einer
Regionalpartei der sich eigentlich nur
darüber ärgert kurz vor der Landtagswahl
dass er sich nicht mehr hinter dem Bund
verstecken kann meine Damen und Herren
und ich sage hier ganz deutlich statt
laut nach harten Maßnahmen zu schreien
die dann wieder von den Gerichten
aufgehoben werden nehmen Sie sich doch
einfach mal ein Beispiel im Süden
Deutschlands an meinem Heimatland
Schleswig-Holstein Impfquote der über
60-Jährigen
90%. Impfquote der 12 bis 17-Jährigen 57
Prozent
booster-impfungen in den Heimen im
August bereits vorbereitet und seit
September finden diese Stadt einen
schönen Gruß mal aus dem schönen Norden
in den Süden statt großartig
Pressekonferenzen zu geben könnte man
auch einfach handeln
und um es an dieser Stelle noch einmal
ganz deutlich zu sagen mit dem Auslaufen
der epidemischen Notlage mit der
Nichtverlängerung wird natürlich nicht
festgestellt dass Corona vorbei ist ich
glaube die Menschen unsere Bevölkerung
ist intelligenter als es die cdu/csu
glaubt die wissen nämlich können die
Lage sehr gut einschätzen meine Damen
und Herren und dazu braucht es nicht der
Verlängerung der epidemischen Lage wir
wollen mit unserem vorgelegten Gesetz
den Ländern die Möglichkeit geben auf
gesetzlicher Grundlage die angemessenen
Maßnahmen die notwendig sind
weiterzuführen
wir werden uns vor allen Dingen das
jetzt durch das Auslaufen der
epidemischen Lage den Ländern Maßnahmen
entzogen würden das stimmt auf jeden
Fall nicht meine Damen und Herren und
eines möchte ich an dieser Stelle auch
noch mal ganz deutlich sagen es muss
jetzt unser aller oberste Priorität sein
die vulnerablen Gruppen zu schützen denn
das vergangene Jahr darf sich nicht
wiederholen und ich glaube da sind wir
uns doch alle einig
konkret müssen wir wie in
Schleswig-Holstein die booster-impfungen
voranbringen wir müssen jeden der eine
alten und Pflegeeinrichtung eine
Einrichtung für Menschen mit Behinderung
betritt jeder muss getestet werden um
diese Gruppen weiterhin gut zu schützen
wir reagieren außerdem indem wir die
Regel am Arbeitsplatz einführen die
Wiedereinführung kostenfreier Test ganz
wichtig wir wollen die Krankenhäuser
finanziell besser ausstatten und wir
bringen einen runden Tisch um die
Menschen zu erreichen die wir bisher bei
den Impfungen noch nicht erreicht haben
das sind konkrete Maßnahmen und das ist
mehr als die
Bundesregierung die letzte überhaupt auf
den Weg gebracht hat meine Damen und
Herren das sind Maßnahmen um
Menschenleben zu retten und das sind
konkrete Maßnahmen die wir jetzt
brauchen wir nehmen die Lage sehr ernst
und ich freue mich auf das Verfahren auf
die Anhörung wir werden gute Maßnahmen
auf den Weg bringen ganz herzlichen Dank
sagt Christine Aschenberg dugnos aus der
FDP-Fraktion in der letzten
Legislaturperiode war sie
gesundheitspolitische Sprecherin ob sie
ihr dieser Legislaturperiode wieder in
diese Position kommt ist noch offen
jetzt aber Jörg Schneider AFD
die neue Bundesregierung möchte die
pandemische Lage
beenden nicht zumindest nicht zum
Besseren
wir haben nämlich die werden auch weiter
von Ihnen hören lassen sie sich impfen
tragen Sie im Bus eine Maske dann wird
alles gut nur wir wissen doch es wird
damit nicht alles gut es funktioniert
nicht denn die alte und die neue
Bundesregierung sie haben eines nicht
verstanden unser Problem ist nicht der
30-Jährige ungeimpfte unser Problem ist
der 30-Jährige geimpfte der seinen
80-jährigen Opa besucht in angeimpfter
Sorglosigkeit lassen sich beide nicht
testen enkelinfiziert den Opa oberlandet
auf der Intensivstation das kriegen sie
vielleicht in den Griff in alten und
Pflegeheimen aber dort wo Opern noch in
der eigenen Wohnung wohnt da bräuchten
sie eigentlich Eigenverantwortung nur
sie neben den Menschen die Freiheit
Freiheit ist aber die Grundlage dafür
dass Menschen Eigenverantwortung
entwickeln keine Freiheit keine
Eigenverantwortung wir werden Corona so
nicht in den Griff bekommen meine Damen
und Herren
sie setzen stattdessen weiter auf
Freiheitsbeschränkungen auf 3G wir haben
doch hier im Bundestag gesehen es
funktioniert nicht unsere konstruierende
Sitzung 700 Abgeordnete ein Tag hier
zusammen
und einer war infiziert rechnen Sie das
mal auf eine wocheninsidenz hoch das ist
eine Wochen Inzidenz von 1000 meine
Damen und Herren der der Abgeordnete
hatte Gott sei Dank einen milden Verlauf
aber das zeigt uns doch zwei Dinge
erstens eine Inzidenz von 1000 ist nicht
zwingend eine Katastrophe und zweitens
sie werden eine Inzidenz von 1000 nicht
mit 3G verhindern meine Damen und Herren
verhindern wollen sich stattdessen das
gefälschte
Impfpässe verwendet werden
das Problem dabei ist es ist zu
fürchterlich einfach ein Impfpass zu
fälschen und dann gehen sie damit zur
Apotheke lassen sich das Ding
digitalisieren damit sind alle Spuren
verwischt der Apotheker naja der Krieg
dafür ein paar Euro für die paar Euro
wird er in der Regel nicht zum
Privatermittler und ich frage sie warum
sorgen sie nicht dafür dass impresse
fälschungssicher werden meine Damen und
Herren
diese neue Regierung
sie wird nichts ändern
die Menschen werden sich in angeimpfter
Sorglosigkeit weiterhin infizieren trotz
3g-level hoch und wir werden auch
weiterhin gefälschte Impfpässe erleben
wenn sie etwas ändern wollen dann folgen
Sie dem Beispiel von Frank von von
Großbritannien folgen Sie den Beispiel
von Dänemark geben Sie den Menschen ihre
Freiheit zurück geben Sie den Menschen
die Basis wieder Eigenverantwortung zu
entwickeln denn auf dieser Art und Weise
können wir tatsächlich diese Pandemie
bekämpfen ich denke mir der 25 November
das ist ein gutes Datum ein gutes Datum
für einen deutschen Tag der Freiheit ich
danke Ihnen
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
DR Jan Marco lucczak und er ist
Rechtspolitiker seiner Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich möchte noch
gerne zurückkommen auf den Anfang
unserer Debatte Bundesminister Scholz
hat sich hier als zukünftiger Kanzler
hingestellt und gesagt das Virus ist
nicht weg und die Lage ist nicht gut
oder er hat Recht damit und das wird
auch
besorgniserregende Weise durch die
Zahlen die wir heute auch wieder hören
deutlich gemacht wir haben 50.000
Neuinfektionen am Tag das ist der
höchste Wert den wir in der Pandemie
jemals gehabt haben wir haben eine
unglaublich hohe Dynamik das sind 50
Prozent mehr Neuinfektionen gegenüber
der Vorwoche die Inzidenz liegt bei 249
in drei Wochen hat sich das fast
verdreifacht die Anzahl von Toten nimmt
zu die Intensivbetten sind mittlerweile
so ausgelastet das wichtige Operationen
verschoben werden müssen dass sie nicht
durchgeführt werden müssen lieber Scholz
und dann sagen sie wenn sie so etwas
sagen das Virus ist nicht weg die Lage
ist nicht gut dann wollen sie doch nicht
allen Ernstes sagen dass die
Voraussetzung für die epidemische Lage
die wir hier im Bundestag miteinander
beschlossen dass es die nicht mehr
vorliegen das ist doch nicht der ernst
meine Damen und Herren und ich will
ihnen sagen ich will ihnen sagen wieso
sie das sagen sie haben offensichtlich
Angst vor der FDP genauso wie im
sondierungspapier haben Sie sich hier
über den Tisch ziehen lassen von einem
falschen Freiheitsverständnis ich sage
Ihnen etwas Freiheit bedeutet auch immer
Verantwortung und Verantwortung bedeutet
an dieser Stelle auch
unbequeme Entscheidungen treffen zu
müssen und natürlich ist die epidemische
Lage eine unbequeme Entscheidung ich
sage aber wenn sie es notwendig ist um
den Schutz der Gesundheit der Menschen
zu gewährleisten da muss man auch den
Mut haben zu dieser unbequemen
Entscheidung und die Ampel hat
offensichtlich nicht diesen Mut meine
Damen und Herren
und dann wundere ich mich das schon ein
bisschen dass die SPD und die Grünen
sich hier ganz offensichtlich in die
Mithaftung nehmen lassen ich sehe den
Kollegen Lauterbach der durch jede
Talkshow klingelt und als großer Maler
dort auftritt sagt was wir alles
brauchen sie sind das Gesicht
offensichtlich der SPD für die
corona-bekämpfung aber sie haben
offensichtlich 0 Durchsetzungskraft in
ihrer eigene Fraktion weil von den
Dingen die sie öffentlich in Talkshows
sagen findet sich in diesem
Gesetzentwurf kein einziges Wort meine
Damen und Herren
wir haben aktuell eine rechtssichere
Grundlage wir haben eine bewährte
Rechtsgrundlage mit dem 28a der aufbaut
auf der fidemischen Grundlage und
wodurch wollen sie das jetzt ersetzen
durch einen Maßnahmenkatalog der in
keiner Weise ausreichend ist der in
keiner Weise entschlossen und zielgenau
gewährleistet dass wir effizient gegen
Corona Vorgehen kennen wir sind uns auch
alle einig wir brauchen flächendecken 2G
ja wo ist denn die Rechtsgrundlage für
eine konkrete rechtssichere
bundeseinheitliche Regelung wo ist denn
die Rechtsgrundlage für verpflichtende
Test in Gemeinschaftseinrichtungen wo
ist denn die Rechtsgrundlage für eine
allgemeines Auskunftsrecht des
Arbeitgebers all das findet sich nicht
in ihrem Gesetzentwurf das ist ein
scheiter mit Ansage was sie hier machen
meine Damen und Herren von der Ampel
und das gleiche gilt für das Thema
Fälschung von impfausweisen die
Bedeutung von impfenausweisen hat in der
Pandemie enorm zugenommen das ist für
den Schutz der Gesundheit für die
Abschätzung von Infektionsrisiken und
für das Vertrauen in die
pandemiebekämpfung eminent wichtig dass
wir uns verlassen können dass
impfnachweise richtig rechtssicher und
valide sind und deswegen sagen wir als
Union ganz klar wer Impfausweise fällt
der muss hart bestraft werden da gibt es
kein Vertun an dieser Stelle und das ist
nach dem momentanen Gesetz des Lage
nicht gewährleistet es gibt
strafbarkeitslücken es gibt
ungerechtfertigte Privilegierungen an
der Stelle und deswegen haben wir als
Union ein Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt der
diese
strafbarkeitslücken schließt wir haben
die Ampel jetzt damit aus unserer Mitte
erstellt Energie gerissen sie haben
jetzt selbst ein Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt
nachdem das Bundesjustizministerium über
Monate sich geweigert hat einen solchen
entsprechenden Gesetzentwurf vorzulegen
da sieht man mal wieder wir machen eine
konstruktive Oppositionspolitik und
Opposition wirkt auch an dieser Stelle
meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage von
Herrn lauterbach
sie haben Recht 2G wäre das was jetzt
notwendig wäre aber ich möchte Sie
fragen also die gestrige Rechtslage gilt
ja noch die epidemische Lage gilt ja
noch das heißt bundesweit wäre 2G durch
die noch amtierende Regierung einführbar
gewesen und demnächst wenn also die neue
Regelung geht ist es durch jedes
Bundesland einführbar das heißt 2G ist
jetzt einführbar deutschlandweit und es
ist demnächst einführbar für jedes
Bundesland ich tingele nicht durch die
Talkshow sondern werde allen geladen und
ich ich
empfehle ich empfehle dort ich empfehle
ich empfehle dort ich empfehle dort
flächendeckend die zwei g-regelung die
wir auch Konto die wir auch
kontrollieren müssen meine Frage ist
jetzt die folgende Visio erwecken Sie
hier den Menschen Eindruck als wenn wir
2G nicht bundesweit und in den einzelnen
Ländern längst machen können also wie so
erwecken sie diesen falschen Eindruck
lieber Herr Kollege Lauterbach also
zunächst einmal ist mir der Unterschied
zwischen durch die Talkshows tingeln und
dort eingeladen werden nicht sehr
geläufig ich glaube es kommt im Ergebnis
auf das Gleiche raus sie haben mit ihrer
Frage ja eigentlich genau das deutlich
gemacht sie haben doch gerade genau
gesagt in der Tat können wir
bundeseinheitlich das Festlegen nach dem
was sie uns jetzt hier mit diesem
Gesetzentwurf vorlegen wird es eben
nicht mehr möglich sein das
bundeseinheitlich fest zu machen sondern
jedes Land muss es selber machen und da
können sie doch nicht abstreiten dass
das ein Minus ist dass es ein weniger
ist gegenüber dem gesetzeszustand den
wir jetzt aktuell haben und deswegen ist
all das was ich hier unisono von der
Ampel vortragen dass man hier mehr
machen können dass es eben kein Minus
ist das stimmt nicht wenn man sich die
Rechtsgrundlagen genau anschaut die sie
jetzt vorgeschlagen haben das was Sie
hier in der Debatte vortragen dass man
das noch machen will dass man noch viele
andere Maßnahmen im parlamentarischen
fahren Verfahren machen möchte wieso
haben sie es denn nicht gleich in den
Gesetz darauf reingeschrieben das ist
eine Mogelpackung die sie machen und
damit bleiben wir sie als Union nicht
durchkommen lassen mit dieser falschen
Argumentation die sich hervorbringen
sie haben noch einen letzten Schlusssatz
ein letzten Schlusssatz möchte ich noch
zu den impfausweisen verwenden der
Gesetzentwurf den die Ampel uns hier
vorgelegt hat der ist absolut
unzureichend die strafbarkeitslücken die
aktuelle existieren werden damit nicht
zweifelsfrei geschlossen die nicht
gerechtfertigen Privilegierung die es
gibt im rechtsustand werden ebenfalls
nicht aufgenommen ich kann nur ein
Beispiel sagen wieso soll zum Beispiel
an Arzt der Corona leugnet und einen
Impfpass falsch ausstellt wieso soll der
eigentlich geringer bestraft werden als
jemand der ohne Arzt zu sein ein
Impfausweis fällt das ist doch ein
Widerspruch wenn jemand seine Stellung
als Arzt missbraucht muss der doch
härter bestraft werden als ein
irgendjemand und das meine Damen und
Herren diese ungerechtfertigten
Differenzierungen in ihrem Gesetzentwurf
die sind nicht Überzeugungen und
deswegen bitte ich um Zustimmung für
unseren Gesetzentwurf er ist besser als
das was in die Ampel uns hier vorgelegt
hat vielen Dank ja Marco Luczak für die
Unionsfraktion und nach einem kleineren
Gefecht mit Karl Lauterbach aus der SPD
und hier ist immer wieder über von
Verantwortung die Rede zwischen Bund
Bundestag und Bundesländern und das gibt
mir noch mal die Gelegenheit zu
verweisen auf die Vertreter auf der
bundesratsbank heute wo du Ramelow ist
da Ministerpräsident von Thüringen und
auch natürlich ist er
Bundesratspräsident und Joachim ist da
der stellvertretende Ministerpräsident
von Nordrhein-Westfalen und jetzt gibt
es Applaus den ich Ihnen noch erklären
muss denn die belarussische
Oppositionspolitikerin dich janowska ja
ist heute hier im Deutschen Bundestag
und wird jetzt gerade von mal eben rüber
schauen klar tatsächlich allen
Fraktionen mit stehendem Beifall bedacht
sie wird hier eine ganze Reihe von
politischen Gesprächen führen in Berlin
heute und
teilweise auch gestern schon wie gesagt
die Abgeordneten haben sich erhoben zu
ihren im Namen
aller
Applaus gerade bemerkt begrüße ich sehr
herzlich und wünsche mir dass auch das
Volk von Belarus in Zukunft seiner
Geschichte seine Geschicke mit freien
und auch parlamentarischen Debatten
gestalten wird
herzlichen Dank für fallen in der
Debatte fort und als nächste Rednerin
für die SPD-Fraktion hat Sabine Dittmann
das Wort und Sabine Dietmar war in der
letzten Legislaturperiode
gesundheitspolitische Sprecherin ihrer
Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir legen heute
einen Gesetzentwurf vor der den Ländern
auch nach dem Ende der Feststellung der
epidemischen Lage von nationaler
Tragweite die Rechtssicherheit geben
wird beim anordnen von den nach wie vor
notwendigen corona-schutzmaßnahmen mit
der erstmaligen Feststellung einer
epidemischen Lage hat der Deutsche
Bundestag im März 2020 im
Infektionsschutzgesetz ein Sonderrecht
geschaffen ein Sonderrecht für die
Bundesregierung und für das
Gesundheitsministerium um Maßnahmen zur
Bewältigung der Pandemie auch per
Rechtsverordnung anzuordnen damit
verbunden war auch die Möglichkeit für
die Länder Schutzmaßnahmen anzuordnen
die mit teils schwerwiegenden
Grundrechtseinschränkungen verbunden
waren und diesen verfassungsrechtlichen
Ausnahmezustand wollen die Fraktionen
der SPD Grüne und FDP beenden und die
Entscheidung wieder ins Parlament zurück
und dass der Zeitpunkt dass der
Zeitpunkt Wohlen richtiger ist sieht man
auch daran dass der Ressort der Ressort
verantwortliche
Bundesgesundheitsminister genau dieses
vorgeschlagen hat die epidemische Lage
nicht weiter zu verlängern und
vielleicht hat Dobrindt Herr Brinkhaus
Herr lutschak sollten Sie dann noch mal
in den Austausch gehen
gleich
wohl die Chemie nicht vorbei sie ist
nicht vorbei wir sind mitten in der
vierten Welle wir erleben mit 50.000
Neuinfektionen am Tag eine
infektionsdynamik eines bislang nicht
gekannten Ausmaßes und die
länderunternehmen aktuell erhebliche
Anstrengungen und das
Infektionsgeschehen in Griff zu kriegen
und sie wünschen sich dafür zu Recht
weiterhin klare rechtliche Grundlagen
und mit dem vorliegenden Gesetzentwurf
stellen wir sicher dass in den Herbst
und Wintermonaten die erforderlichen und
auch bewerten Instrumentarien weiterhin
zum Einsatz kommen können maskenpflicht
Abstandsgebot 3G 2G Hygienekonzepte
kapazitätsbegrenzung
aber liebe Bürgerinnen Liebe Bürger wir
wollen
wir müssen und wir werden weiterhin
dafür Sorge tragen dass die schwächsten
und verletzlichsten in unserer
Gesellschaft so gut wie möglich
geschützt werden können
Pflegebedürftige und Kranke sollen
weiterhin Besuch von ihren Angehörigen
bekommen können Kitas und Schulen sollen
geöffnet bleiben und deshalb müssen wir
das Umfeld dieser besonderen
schutzbedürftigen Gruppen so sicher wie
möglich machen wir wollen absichern wir
wollen absichern das Beschäftigte bei
ihrer Arbeit bestmöglichst sind und
Betriebe
nahrungsvoll weitergeführt werden können
und deshalb sprechen wir in den
laufenden Verhandlungen über notwendige
Ergänzungen des Gesetzentwurfs dazu
gehören die testpflichten für
Beschäftigte und Besucherinnen Besucher
im Pflegeeinrichtungen wer als
Beschäftigter nicht genesen oder geimpft
ist wird sich täglich testen lassen
müssen aber auch für geimpfte und
genesinnen wird es in gewissen Bereichen
regelmäßig verpflichtende Tests geben
deshalb werden wir auch die kostenlosen
bürgertests wieder einführen
meine Damen und Herren Kolleginnen und
Kollegen was wir jetzt erleben
exponentielles Infektionsgeschehen
Regionen mit Inzidenzen über 1000 ein
volllaufender Intensivstationen
Pflegekräfte und Ärzte die am Limit
arbeiten
Alters hat einen Grund
sie ist der Tatsache geschuldet dass 16
Millionen Erwachsene und 2,5 Millionen
Jugendliche noch immer nicht geimpft
sind dass die Immunität mit zunehmenden
Abstand zur Impfung abnimmt
aber auch dass wir zwischenzeitlich
wieder ein sehr viel sorgloseres
miteinander erleben Kollegin Dittmar
unsere intensivstadt Kollegen Dietmar
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage aus der
afd-fraktion nein nein Herr münzenbacher
unsere
Intensivstationen
sind voll mit Menschen die sich mit
einer Impfung hätten schützen können
als Medizinerin kann ich nicht logisch
nach Erfolg ziehen und erklären warum
die Angst vor äußerst seltenen
Nebenwirkungen bei einer Impfung warum
diese Angst schwerer wiegt als die Angst
davor mit Lungenversagen und schweren
Langzeitfolgen auf der Intensivstation
beatmet
und dabei liegt der Weg dabei liegt der
Weg aus der Pandemie auf der Hand die
Wiese lautet impfen impfen impfen
Impflücken schließen und beim Boostern
schneller werden lassen Sie uns die
bevorstehenden intensiven Beratungen
über Fraktionsgrenzen hinweg dafür alles
tun damit Corona aus unseren Leben aus
unserem Alltag zurückgedrängt wird
Sabine Dittmer aus der SPD-Fraktion auch
sie war maßgeblich beteiligt an diesem
Gesetzentwurf der hier gerade diskutiert
wird der am Montag in einer Anhörung
kommt und am nächsten Donnerstag dann zu
zweiter und dritter Lesung wieder hier
ins Parlament kommen wird um dann auch
abgestimmt zu werden
nächste Rednerinnen achso diesen kleinen
Hinweis noch Aidan özos jetzt an der
Spitze des Bundestags Präsidiums
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin hat
abgelöst und jetzt Nina Wagen für die
Unionsfraktion
für den Umgang mit der Pandemie in der
aktuellen Lage
und der
Gesetzentwurf der hier vorgelegt wurde
und als großer Befreiungsschlag verkauft
wird ist insofern paradox als das darin
die Maßnahmen die bislang auf Grundlage
der Notlage verhängt werden konnten in
abgespeckter unzureichender Form bis
März fortgelten sollen es ist nicht mehr
so dass alle drei Monate die Notlage
durch das Parlament künftig festgestellt
werden kann aktuell kann die Geltung der
epidemischen Lage hier im Plenum nach
Abstimmung beendet und mit kurzen
Vorlauf wieder eingesetzt werden und
künftig braucht es für Änderungen der
Maßnahmen ein Gesetz das ist für die
Eindämmung einer Pandemie ein viel zu
behäbiges Vorgehen meine Damen und
Herren
und mit den Plänen
verkürzen auch die künftigen
Koalitionäre auch wenn es hier anders
dargestellt wird die Rechte des Hohen
Hauses die geben sie nicht an das
Parlament zurück wie es hier die FDP uns
weiß machen will auch das gehört zur
Wahrheit dazu liebe Kollegen
vor allem aber weiß der eingebrachte
Gesetzentwurf einige Lücken auf und
bleibt auch hinter dem zurück was gerade
heute in den Reden vollmundig
angekündigt wurde es fehlen klare
Regelungen für 2G und 3G am Arbeitsplatz
mit einem Auskunftsrecht des
Arbeitgebers und auch die finanzielle
Unterstützung von Krankenhäusern ist
bisher nur angekündigt aber auch noch
nicht verankert und die länderrechte
werden eingeschränkt insgesamt kann man
sagen das scheinbar mehr Rücksicht auf
im Verweigerer genommen wird als auf
jene die sich zum Wohle aller für eine
Impfung entschieden haben meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren die Pandemie
hat uns allen viel abverlangt und damit
wir mit der gebotenen Vorsicht ein
bisschen mehr Normalität in unserem
Leben möglich machen können braucht es
verlässliche Regeln die 2G und
drei-regelungen bieten solche
Voraussetzungen und darum müssen wir
auch auf sie vertrauen können und nicht
fürchten müssen dass die Person am
Nachbartisch im Restaurant einen
gefälschten Nachweis vorgelegt hat doch
da gibt es eben straf freiheitslücken
die wir seit längerem schon schließen
wollen als Union jetzt endlich mit
Einbringung unseres Gesetzentwurfs haben
auch die ampelparteien diesen Punkt
aufgegriffen die Schritte gehen in die
richtige Richtung aber sie reichen
dagegenwärtigen Situation nicht aus wir
fordern eine härtere Bestrafung für
impfpassfälschungen und für die Nutzung
dieser gefälschten Dokumente meine Damen
und Herren sagen wir wie es ist man
merkt dass die drei Parteien an Spagat
schaffen müssen zwischen dem was Grüne
und FDP lautstark in der Opposition
gefordert haben dem was sie in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen unter einen Hut
bringen müssen und dem was die wirklich
zunehmend dramatische corona-lage als
gebotenes Handeln erfordert die
rot-grün-gelbe Selbstfindungsphase liebe
Kollegen strahlt der eingebrachte
Gesetzentwurf aus wir brauchen aber
Führung und Sicherheit und um diesen
unsicheren Kurs entgegenzusteuern werden
wir uns ans Union auch im weiteren
parlamentarischen Verfahren konstruktiv
einbringen vielen
vielen Dank
ich schließe die Aussprache
interfraktionell wird Überweisung der
Gesetzentwürfe auf den Drucksachen 15
und 27 an den Hauptausschuss
vorgeschlagen ich gehe davon aus dass es
keine weiteren überweisungsvorschläge
gibt dann verfahren wir wie
vorgeschlagen
ich rufe auf die tagungsordnungspunkte
4a und 4b Beratung des Antrags der
Fraktion der cdu/csu mit dem Titel
Migration ordnen steuern und begrenzen
neue pulfaktoren verhindern Lukaschenko
stoppen sowie Beratung des Antrags der
Fraktion der AFD mit dem Titel
Solidarität mit den europäischen
Partnern Unterstützung für die Maßnahmen
Polens Ungarns und anderer europäischer
Staaten zur Abwehr destabilisierender
migrationsbewegung
für die Aussprache ist eine Dauer von 31
Minuten beschlossen
ich warte noch mal bis es etwas ruhiger
wird und das gibt mir die Gelegenheit
hier zu sagen dass hier die eine und
andere Welt im Moment ein bisschen
aufeinanderprallen nämlich auf der einen
Seite sehen wie hier karnevalskappen ist
es ja der 11.11 und offenbar auch 11:11
gewesen vor kurzem und auf der anderen
Seite jetzt aber hier ein schwieriges
sein kompliziertes aktuelles Thema unter
anderem auch mit der belarussischen
Oppositionspolitikerin tichanowskaja auf
der Gast Tribüne und der erste Redner
zum Thema Ordnung Steuerung und
Begrenzung von Migration das alles vor
dem Hintergrund der Lage an der
polnischen Grenze erste Redner ist
Thorsten frei aus der Unionsfraktion ist
eine menschliche Tragödie die wir nicht
zum ersten Mal erleben wir haben das
schon erlebt an der
türkisch-griechischen Grenze an der
marokkanisch spanischen Grenze das
Menschen eingesetzt werden auf eine ganz
perfide Weise um außen und
machtpolitische Ziele zu erreichen das
ist die Tat eines Diktators Lukaschenko
unter tätiger mithilfe von Erdogan und
Putin und das dürfen wir denen nicht
durchgehen lassen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und deshalb ist es so entscheidend dass
wir an dieser Stelle auch mit dem
EU-Mitgliedstaat Polen absolut
solidarisch sind übrigens nicht nur mit
Polen sondern auch mit den anderen
baltischen Staaten mit Litauen mit
Lettland die ihren Beitrag dazu leisten
dass europäische Außengrenzen gesichert
werden die Grundvoraussetzung dafür dass
es keine Binnengrenzen in einem
vereinigten Europa geben muss dafür
brauchen wir einen effektiven
außengrenzschutz das macht Polen und
deswegen werden dort nicht nur polnische
sondern europäische Interessen vertreten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und
deshalb verdient das Land auch unsere
Unterstützung und ich will an dieser
Stelle sagen dass es Grund falsch ist
wenn man jetzt hingeht und ein Beitrag
dazu leistet dass das Kalkül von
Lukaschenko aufgeht und das tut
derjenige der sagt diejenigen die dort
im Grenzgebiet sind sollen jetzt in
Europa verteilt werden
damit geht es Kalkül von Lukaschenko auf
damit wird der Druck auf die polnische
Grenze verstärkt und damit wird ein
Spaltpilz in die Europäische Union
getrieben das ist das Dümmste was man an
dieser Stelle fordern kann liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich gebe mich mach ihnen einen Vorschlag
ich mache Ihnen einen Vorschlag entweder
sie stellen eine Zwischenfrage oder sie
halten ihren Mund aber so geht es nicht
es ist absolut unparlamentarisch wie sie
sich verhalten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen kommen
wir zur Sachpolitik zurück vor diesem
Hintergrund ist es besonders
alarmierend dass wir mit einer Situation
konfrontiert werden wo wir in den ersten
zehn Monaten diesen Jahres
150.000 Asylanträge haben allein in den
letzten vier Wochen
20.000 und vor diesem Herr Kollege frei
sie haben es ein bisschen provoziert
jetzt möchte Herr Kollege Kleinwächter
erstmal eine Frage stellen
Kollege Frey vielen Dank für diese
Zwischenfrage auch Werte frau
Präsidentin vielen Dank dass Sie mir das
Wort erteilt haben sie müssen schon
unsere Erregung etwas entschuldigen Herr
frei weil sie reden hier gerade und
stellen eine Politik dar die Deutschland
unter einer CDU geführten
Bundesregierung von Angela Merkel ja
völlig anders erlebt hat als was sie
gerade darstellt was sie sagen ist
völlig richtig dass die Außengrenzen
geschützt werden müssen dass wir endlich
Solidarität mit unseren polnischen
Nachbarn üben müssen aber die Realität
ist doch eine andere ich war letzte
Woche in Polen ich war an der OST
polnischen Grenze übrigens der einzige
Vertreter Deutschlands der sich
überhaupt irgendwo hat blicken lassen
das wurde mir bestätigt am letzten
Dienstag und ich muss sie an dieser
Stelle schon fragen wenn uns unsere
polnischen Freunde fragen sagt mal warum
erkennt eigentlich die Bundesregierung
nicht wie gefährlich das ist warum
erkennt Deutschland nicht wie gefährlich
das ist dass da viele tausende Menschen
kommen oft mit is-verbindungen und warum
hört Deutschland nicht endlich auf
dieser Magnet zu sein für all diese
Menschen durch Aufnahme in Sozialsystem
die eben nicht nur theoretisch möglich
sondern praktisch erwiesen ist nachdem
sich eine Regierung Merkel mit ihrer
koalitionsverantwortung erpressbar
gemacht hat mit einem eu-türkei-deal wie
kommen sie jetzt bitteschön auf die Idee
eine solche Rede zu halten wo sie all
das fordern was sie im Endeffekt
negiert haben als ihre Partei in der
Regierung war
Herr Kollege das was sie darstellt ist
wirklich rundum falsch wenn sie sich mal
die Politik in der Vergangenheit
anschauen dann sehen sie dass die alte
Koalition aus cdu/csu und SPD im
Frühsommer 2019 ein großes
migrationspaket besteht aus acht
Gesetzen verabschiedet hat indem wir
genau die Punkte die Not getan haben
auch entsprechend adressiert haben und
ich will ihnen das ganz deutlich sagen
indem wir einen klaren Unterschied
machen zwischen der Arbeitsmigration auf
der einen Seite und der asyl- und
fluchtmigration auf der anderen Seite
genau das haben wir im zweiten Gesetz
zur besseren Durchsetzung der
Ausreisepflicht dem
fachkräfteeinwanderungsgesetze und
anderen Gesetzen statuiert und deshalb
waren wir dort im übrigen auch auf dem
richtigen Weg ich will Ihnen ein zweites
Beispiel nennen gemeinsam mit der SPD
haben wir dort dafür gesorgt dass
pull-faktoren reduziert werden warum
weil wir die Bezugsdauer des
Asylbewerber belastungsgesetzes von 15
auf 18 Monate verlängert haben und dafür
gesorgt haben dass wenn jemand nach
Deutschland kommt obwohl er in einem
anderen Land bereits ein Asylantrag
gestellt hat die bezugsvoraussetzungen
abgesenkt werden das ist eine Politik
die Sinn macht und deswegen fordere ich
an dieser Stelle auch die SPD auf dass
sie die Mitte nicht verlässt in der
Migrationspolitik dass sie sich von den
Grünen nicht nach links ziehen lässt und
das rückabwickelt was wir in der
vergangenen Legislaturperiode gemeinsam
gemacht haben und deswegen
da bin ich ja weil der Herr Lindner so
lacht da bin ich ja ganz besonders auf
die FDP gespannt die im Grunde genommen
des Gegenteil von dem sagt was die
Grünen wollen und ich will ihnen eines
sagen wenn man sich das
sondierungspapier anschaut dann sieht
man die Erfolglosigkeit der Grünen im
Bereich der Klimapolitik und das wird
offensichtlich überkompensiert durch
eine einladende Migrationspolitik das
wird mit uns nicht zu machen sein
herzlichen Dank
Thorsten frei aus der Unionsfraktion
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
dort in dieser Debatte zur
flüchtlingslage an den EU-Außengrenzen
nächster Redner auf der Liste ist der
geschäftsführende Bundesaußenminister
Heiko Maas
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir kennen alle
die entsetzlichen Bilder die uns aus dem
belaristischen Grenzgebiet zu Polen und
den baltischen Staaten erreichen und das
nicht erst seit den letzten Tagen
hunderte Menschen sind dort an der
Grenze gestrandet angeleitet von
belarussischen Sicherheitskräften die
Ihnen jetzt gewaltsam den Rückweg
versperren Kinder Frauen und Männer
campieren in Eiseskälte ohne
ausreichende Bekleidung unter freiem
Himmel und mittlerweile sind auch
Menschen ums Leben gekommen
und verantwortlich für dieses Leid ist
Herr Lukaschenko und seine Helfer in
Minsk und ich will an der Stelle sagen
unabhängig von anderen politischen
Diskussionen die wir in der Europäischen
Union führen
das Problem und so habe ich manchmal den
Eindruck in der Debatte in dieser Frage
ist nicht Polen sondern das Problem ist
Lukaschenko und Belarus und das Regime
das ist dort gibt und deshalb hat Polen
in dieser soll in dieser Situation
unsere Solidarität europäische
Solidarität verdient
[Applaus]
meine Damen und Herren
die Machthaber in Milch sie bringen
Migranten und Migranten unter
Vorspiegelung falscher Tatsachen nach
Belarus um sie von dort in Richtung
Europäischer Union zu schicken ohne
jedes Gruppe missbrauchen sie tausende
von Menschen als Geisel für ein
zynisches Machtspiel und sie wollen die
Europäische Union und einzelne
Mitgliedstaaten wie insbesondere Polen
aber auch Litauen unter Druck setzen und
sie spielen skrupellos dabei mit
Menschenleben
und währenddessen nur ums auch mal zu
erwähnen geht auch die Repression gegen
das belarussische Volk weiter seit dem
vergangenen Jahr haben Sicherheitskräfte
des Regimes tausende Menschen
festgenommen die Zahl der politischen
Gefangenen ist auf über 800 gestiegen
und ein Dialog mit der Opposition findet
nicht statt meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren wir sind in einer Situation
in der es
vielleicht emotional nahe liegt Herr
Lukaschenko zu beschimpfen aber das
reicht bei weitem nicht mehr aus wir
sind in einer Situation in der es
überfällig ist jetzt die richtigen
Konsequenzen zu ziehen und das wollen
wir auch und zwar mit unseren
europäischen Partnern erstens die
humanitäre Versorgung der Menschen im
belarussischen Grenzgebiet hat Priorität
besonders Angesicht des nahenden Winters
zu den Grundwerten der Europäischen
Union und ihrer Mitgliedstaaten gehört
dass wir Menschen in Not nicht alleine
lassen diese gemeinsamen Werte werden
uns auch werden wir auch an unseren
Außengrenzen hochhalten müssen das
gebietet das Völkerrecht gerade in
dieser Situation
humanitären Zugang zu gewähren
internationale Hilfsorganisationen und
zivilgesellschaftliche Vereinigung
stehen bereit um den Menschen in Polen
aber auch in Belarus zu helfen und das
muss möglich gemacht werden
zweitens
zweitens wir werden als Europäische
Union gegen illegale Schleusung durch
Belarus weiter vorgehen niemand soll
sich ungestraft an diesem schleuserring
beteiligen können und das ist eine
Botschaft an die Transitstaaten die
Herkunftsstaaten und die
Fluggesellschaften mit denen Migranten
und mit kranken von nach Belarus
gebracht werden ihnen muss klar sein
dass die Europäische Union nicht bereit
sein wird dass länger zu akzeptieren und
diese Botschaft kommt auch an in den
Herkunftsländern haben wir mittlerweile
viele Gespräche geführt die zum Beispiel
dazu geführt haben dass im Irak und
jordanienflüge nach Belarus eingestellt
worden sind wir reden auch mit den
Fluggesellschaften es ist rechtlich
nicht einfach Fluggesellschaften
zu sanktionieren weil sie
formalrechtlich nicht illegales tun aber
wir haben allen Fluggesellschaften
mittlerweile mitgeteilt dass
möglicherweise auf EU-Ebene es kein
sektionsregime gibt aber dass die
Mitgliedstaaten der Europäischen Union
sehr wohl überlegen
diejenigen die Mittäter eines
schleuserrings sind in Haftung zu nehmen
und landechte werden in jedem einzelnen
Mitgliedstaat selbst erteilt und auch
das ist ein Thema mit dem sich diese
Fluggesellschaften ernsthaft
auseinandersetzen müssen drittens
die Europäische Union wird ihre
Sanktionen gegen Lukaschenkos Regime
ausweiten und verschärfen und das werden
wir am Montag im Außenrad in Brüssel
beschließen diejenigen Personen und
Unternehmen die sich an der gezielten
Schleusung beteiligen werden wir weiter
sanktionieren und zwar überall auf der
Welt und zudem liegen weitere Optionen
auf dem Tisch etwa die Ausweitung schon
bestehender und anderer
Sanktionsregime durchzuführen
insbesondere die sogenannten sektoralen
Sanktionen also wirtschaftliche es ist
in der Vergangenheit durchaus gesagt
worden dass zu viel
Wirtschaftssanktionen die Abhängigkeit
Belarus von Russland weiter verschärfen
wir sind mittlerweile an einer Situation
an dem die Konsequenzen aber klarer
werden müssen und deshalb bin ich auch
der Auffassung dass so wichtige
Wirtschaftszweige wie die Kaliindustrie
in Belarus jetzt sanktioniert werden
muss und das trägt die Mehrheit der
europäischen Union mit Herr Minister
erlauben sie eine weitere Zwischenfrage
von Herrn Kleinwächter
nein viertens wir intensivieren unsere
wir intensivieren und das würde ich
bitten nicht zu unterschätzen jeder der
das in Zweifel zieht muss man sich daran
erinnern dass das auf dem Westbalkan
gewirkt hat nämlich unsere
Aufklärungsarbeit in den
Herkunftsländern zu verbessern
Reisebüros und Schleuserbanden locken
Menschen auf die gefährliche Reise nach
Belarus weil sie damit Geld verdienen
können und sie ziehen in diesen Menschen
dafür Tausende von Dollar möglicherweise
das letzte was sie haben aus der Tasche
und deshalb müssen wir mit den Lügen der
Schleusern und den Gerüchten in der
sozialen Medien aufräumen und auch die
Folgen aufzeigen die Lukaschenkos für
jeden einzelnen hat der sich überlegt
auf die Reise zu begeben und deshalb
meine Damen und Herren in dieser
Situation stehen wir solidarisch an der
Seite unserer europäischen Partner in
Polen und in Litauen
und die jüngsten Ereignisse zeigen auch
noch einmal mehr wir brauchen
nachhaltige und menschliche Lösungen in
den Bereichen Flucht und Migration und
das heißt Fortschritte hin zu einem
gemeinsamen europäischen Asylsystem das
migrationsursachen angeht europäische
Grenzen schützt aber vor allem
solidarisch ist und dafür werden wir uns
auf europäischer Ebene weiter einsetzen
vielen Dank
Heiko Maas geschäftsführender
Bundesaußenminister in einer Debatte in
der es insbesondere um die
Flüchtlingslager an der polnisch Bela
russischen Grenze geht und in dieser
Debatte ist jetzt an der Reihe Franziska
Brandner aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen wo sie Parlamentarische
Geschäftsführerin ist
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
die Lage der Menschen an den Grenzen an
der Grenze zwischen Polen und Belarus
ist furchtbar ich finde sie unerträglich
und sie ist auf jeden Fall inakzeptabel
und deswegen Herr frei werde ich sie
auch nicht benutzen für offensichtliche
Scharmützel
und meine Kolleginnen Julian Pahlke und
Merle Spellerberg Herr Kleinwächter
waren auch dort
und es ist eine sehr schwierige
Situation für Polen für unsere
baltischen Partner und deswegen lassen
Sie mich ganz klar sagen wir werden
Polen wir werden unsere baltischen
Partner nicht alleine lassen in dieser
schwierigen Zeit
und europäische Solidarität bedeutet
Hilfe für Polen humanitäre Hilfe Hilfe
bei den Kontrollen der Registrierung der
Versorgung bei der Aufnahme und ich
hoffe dass die polnische Regierung die
europäischen Unterstützungsangebote doch
noch annehmen wird und dass die
geschäftsführende Regierung darauf
drängt dass Ärztinnen
Hilfsorganisationen JournalistInnen
endlich wieder Zugang zu dem Grenzgebiet
haben
denn Menschen Kinder
dort erfrieren und verhungern zu lassen
das darf keine europäische Politik sein
wir sind
anders als Lukaschenko und das müssen
wir auch bleiben und das wird sich genau
in dem Umgang mit dieser Krise zeigen
und
wir werden auch unsere Grenze zu Polen
nicht schließen denn wir lassen uns
nicht spalten die CDU hat in ihrem
Antrag die Grenzkontrollen einer
deutsch-polnischen Grenze
gefordert ich finde das kontraproduktiv
denn es bestraft die falschen es wird
straft jene Menschen die aus Polen und
Deutschland sich für ein europäisches
Leben über die Grenzen hinweg
entschieden haben
sie spielen damit jeden in die Hände die
die USD stabilisieren wollen nämlich
Lukaschenko und Putin diese tragen die
Verantwortung für das humanitäre
Desaster was wir dort sehen Lukaschenko
instrumentalisiert Menschen indem man
sie aus Damaskus Dubai Istanbul oder
Moskau einfliegt ja
instrumentalisiert sie aber trotzdem
sind diese Menschen keine Waffe sie sind
keine Verhandlungsmasse sondern sie sind
Menschen mit ihrer Würde
und der Umgang mit diesen Menschen
der Zeit was für ein unmenschliches
Regime in Minsk herrscht und deswegen
muss jetzt die Priorität sein alles zu
tun um diese staatliche Schleuse tun zu
unterbinden und ja hier muss die
Europäische Union einstehen wir dürfen
uns nicht spalten lassen und deswegen
braucht es nächste Woche weitere
Sanktionen Herr Maaß sie haben es
erwähnt harte Sanktion gegen das
belarushesische Regime und ja auch gegen
die Wirtschaft gegen die kahleindustrie
gegen diese Wirtschaftszweige die sehr
von uns profitieren Frau Kollegin
Brandner erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage
aus der AFD
die Weihnachtszeit ist ja auch eine
beliebte Einkaufszeit in München oder
anderen deutschen Städten gerade für
welche aus der Macht klicke aus Belarus
das muss doch nicht sein
außerdem braucht es Konsequenzen für die
Fluglinien die Menschen aus dem Irak aus
Syrien oder anderen Ländern nach Belarus
fliegen Herr Maaß sie haben es
angedeutet ich hoffe dass wir da von der
geschäftsführenden Regierung auch
konkrete Schritte sehen werden und es
braucht Aufklärung vor Ort um die
Menschen vor den perfiden lok-angeboten
lukaschenkoes zu warnen auch da hoffe
ich dass die aktuelle geschäftsführende
Regierung noch etwas auf den Weg bringt
aber vor allem gibt es einen der das
belarussische Regime noch am Leben hält
und diesen perfiden Erpressungsversuch
deckt Vladimir Putin
und wir müssen hier eine neue Politik
des Dialogs und der Härte voranbringen
wir müssen unsere Verwundbarkeiten
abbauen und das geht nicht von heute auf
morgen das weiß ich sehr wohl aber das
ist eine der großen Aufgaben der
nächsten Regierung
und lassen sie mich zum Schluss bitte
noch einmal betonen
wie bewundernswert ich es finde was sie
Zivilgesellschaft in Polen aber auch in
Belarus gerade leistet viele Polinnen
und Polen leisten vor Ort akute Nothilfe
für die geflüchteten in Belarus kämpfen
die Menschen weiterhin für Freiheit
Demokratie und Menschenrechte und
stellvertretend dafür möchte ich Frau
tiranowskaja die uns ja heute hier
beehrt hat danken
und ich möchte
zusichern wir stehen an ihrer Seite
Franziska Brandner noch mal mit einem
Verweis auf die Bela russische
Oppositionspolitikerin tichanowskaja die
allerdings die ersten Bundestag das
wieder verlassen hat sie war ja kurz zu
Gast auf der Besuchertribüne und hier
geht es jetzt weiter in der Debatte über
die Flüchtlingslager an den Außengrenzen
der EU und es kommt ein Vertreter der
Länder zu Wort nämlich der
stellvertretende Ministerpräsident von
Nordrhein-Westfalen und Minister für
Kinder Familie Flüchtlinge und
Integration Joachim Stamm
Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren
ich möchte an dieser Stelle damit
beginnen mit dem klaren Bekenntnis dass
nicht nur Bundestag sondern
selbstverständlich auch der Bundesrat
fest an der Seite der Opposition in
Belarus steht und dass wir keinen
Erpressungsversuchen von Lukaschenko
nachgeben dürfen
meine Damen und Herren der
Bundesaußenminister hat die wesentlichen
Dinge hier vorgetragen es ist ganz
entscheidend dass wir zusammenstehen
auch in der Unterstützung von Polen die
alle Hilfen verdient haben sowohl bei
der humanitären Versorgung weil
natürlich Kolleginnen Brandner hat ja
eben darauf hingewiesen keine Menschen
sterben dürfen in unserem
Verantwortungsbereich und wir hier ein
Imperativ haben aber genauso braucht
Polen eben auch die Unterstützung bei
der Sicherung unserer gemeinsamen
europäischen Außengrenze
man muss die Hilfen
man muss die Hilfen dann natürlich auch
annehmen auch das gehört zur Wahrheit
dazu und meine Damen und Herren es
stehen ja verschiedene Diskussionen aus
der Wissenschaft im Raum ich denke wir
sollten uns auch noch einmal Gedanken
machen wie durch
multilaterale Abkommen auch in Zukunft
die Europäische Union weniger erpressbar
wird
das ist eine schwierige Situation in der
wir sind und Herr Kollege frei ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob das der richtige Weg
ist innenpolitische Polemik hier in die
Debatte zu bringen und
ich war etwas erstaunt auch in ihrem
Antrag Herr Brinkhaus über die Polemik
gegen den Spurwechsel in
Nordrhein-Westfalen
hat die
erfolgreiche Koalition von CDU und NRW
den Spurwechsel möglich gemacht damit
gut integrierter Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer nicht abgeschoben werden
und er bringt aus vielleicht hören sie
mir zu er bringt aus vielleicht hören
sie mir zu
Handwerk und insbesondere kleine und
mittlere Unternehmen danken uns dass Sie
die Wahl verloren haben das hat auch was
damit zu tun dass ihre Innenpolitiker in
dieser Fraktion fachlich nicht mehr auf
der Höhe der Zeit sind
Herr Abgeordneter frei ich lade Sie Herr
Abgeordneter frei ich lade Sie herzlich
ein kommen Sie mal zu uns nach
Nordrhein-Westfalen schauen Sie sich
unsere migrations- und
Integrationspolitik an wir schieben
konsequenter als jedes andere Bundesland
Straftäter und Gefährder ab aber wir
schaffen für fleißige wir schaffen für
fleißige Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer auch die notwendige
Rechtssicherheit vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Stamm
für die afd-fraktion hat jetzt das Wort
dr Gottfried Curio
sehr geehrte Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren wir erleben den Offenbarungseid
der deutschen Migrationspolitik und der
Hauptschuldige spielt schnell ein
bisschen AFD wir stellen fest
Einwanderung ist kein Menschenrecht
illegaler Grenzübertritt ist ein
krimineller Akt die Abwehr illegaler
Migration ist staatsspflicht Deutschland
verletzt diese Pflicht eklatant Polen
hingegen schützt sich Deutschland und
die ganze EU binnenfreizügigkeit hat den
Schutz der Außengrenzen zur notwendigen
Voraussetzung Polen handelt in unserem
Interesse da die Migranten auf ihrer
Reise durch sicheren Drittstaaten
offenbar keinen Schutz suchen sondern
nur den Weg ins abzockschlaraffenland
Deutschland wer vor Polens Grenze
Germany schreit sucht nicht Asyl und
Polen braucht jetzt keinen
Etikettenschwindel wie Frontex sondern
wirklich effektive Unterstützung gegen
die Angreifer die mit Steinen werfen und
Grenzanlagen niederreißen wo die Grenzen
löchrig sind wie Schweizer Käse will
Deutschland noch den Käse wegnehmen und
nur die Löcher übrig lassen pol will die
Löcher stopfen nicht Brüssel nicht NATO
nicht Merkel verteilt in Deutschland das
tut nur noch Polen dafür schulden wir
ihm unsere volle Unterstützung meine
Damen und Herren
aber der cdu-burg will sich jetzt als
Gärtner aufspielen mit seinen alten trug
Worten Migration ordnen und Steuern neue
pulfaktoren verhindern wie wäre es denn
mal damit alte pulfaktoren zu verhindern
übermäßige Sozialleistung für Migranten
offene Grenzen nie erfolgende
Abschiebung wofür diese Union samt SPD
verantwortlich sind ordnen heißt bei
denen das Chaos durchnummerieren Steuern
heißt weiter in den Abgrund das sind die
Leute die die nicht die Probleme der
weltweiten illegalen Migration nach
Deutschland lösen wollen nein sie haben
sie aller erst geschaffen solche
Heuchelei wie im unionsantrag braucht
niemand
lukaschen stoppen Sie doch mal die
Kriminellen Angreifer da werden nicht
Arme Migranten die nicht wissen wie
ihnen geschieht für irgendwas
instrumentalisiert die machen genau das
was sie selbst wollen diese Täter haben
ihre Lage selbst herbeigeführt um sich
eine Rundumversorgung in Deutschland zu
erpressen denn Deutschland ist das
Problem nur weil Deutschland nicht sagt
wir nehmen euch nicht wir zahlen für
euch nicht nur deshalb haben wir solche
Probleme
mit Lukas schenkow sucht man einen Alibi
fürs eigene Versagen mit Weißrusslands
Durchlässigkeit als Transitland für
migrationshelie Glücksritter handelt der
aber sogar genau gemäß dem globalen
migrationspakt von ihnen initiiert das
ist nur Umsiedlung pur um jeden Preis
Micheline die illegale Migranten übers
Mittelmeer bringen nennen sich jetzt
unverhohlen Team Umvolkung also helfen
dir Polen bei der
Effe der gemeinsamen Außengrenze so geht
steuern und begrenzen aber Herr Harbeck
will stattdessen die Leute reinholen und
so die illegale Migration weiter
anheizen er findet halt Vaterlands Liebe
zum Kotzen wusste noch nie mit
Deutschland was anzufangen so ein
Minister wäre eine Schande für
Deutschland meine Damen und Herren und
wenn Merkel meint wir haben das
geschafft werden sich vor unseren Augen
ein zweites 20 15 abspielt die
Urkatastrophe des 21 jahrhunderts
wiederholt sich wir sagen das darf nicht
sein bewahren wir das Recht bewahren wir
Deutschland meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
das Wort hat für die Fraktion DIE LINKE
Türkei Akbulut
sehr geehrte Frau da jetzt sehr geehrte
Frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen mindestens zehn Menschen sind
bereits an der Grenze vom Polen zu
Belarus gestorben zehn Menschen die
nicht hätten sterben müssen hätte man
geltendes Recht an der EU-Außengrenze
eingehalten täglich werden Menschen
Opfer von illegalen pushbacks von Polen
nach Belarus und auch an den auch an den
europäischen Grenzen ich selber betreue
einige solche Fälle als Abgeordnete und
stehen im Austausch mit vielen NGOs ich
möchte hier nochmal betonen dass die EU
und Menschenrechte maßstabpolitischen
Handels sein müssen und nicht die
Erzählung das geflüchtete Menschen als
Waffen eingesetzt werden
Schutzsuchende sind keine Waffen und
keine Kriegsparteien
die druckweisung von geflüchteten ohne
individuelle Prüfung des Asylverfahrens
ist ein eindeutiger Verstoß gegen die
Genfer Flüchtlingskonvention gegen die
Europäische Menschenrechtskonvention und
gegen geltendes eu-asylrecht diese
Rechte
Frau Kollegin Akbulut erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage des Kollegen frohmeyer von
der AFD
wir müssen weitermachen diese Rechte
können nicht durch nationale
Gesetzgebung ausgehebelt werden wie es
derzeit Polen immer wieder versucht hier
gegen muss die Europäische Kommission
endlich Vorgehen die EU darf sich
gegenüber Lukaschenko nicht der pressbar
machen heißt es immer wieder aber die EU
hat sich doch selbst in diese Lage
gebracht weil sie die Aufnahme einer
überschaubaren Zahl von Schutzsuchenden
als Bedrohung dargestellt hat doch was
sind ein paar tausend Menschen auf 450
Millionen europäische Bürgerinnen und
Bürger verteilt das ist doch einfach und
tragbar diese diese Situation an der
Grenze erschreckend ist wie sehr das
Recht den narrativ der Abschottung um
jeden Preis die Asyldebatte inzwischen
in Deutschland bestimmt
2015 wurde die Forderung der AFD die
Grenzen zu schließen und auch
Flüchtlinge zurückzuweisen und notfalls
mit zollen und schussbefehl noch
einheilig zurückgewiesen aber inzwischen
wird der Bau von Mauern propagiert und
man nimmt tote Menschen an der
Grenze scheinbar Axel zuckend hier in
Kauf wir möchten uns aber nicht an diese
Bilder gewöhnen Deutschland und die
Europäische Union dürfen nicht weiter
Teil ein des Wettbewerbs der Brutalität
sein und das menschenverachtende Spiel
lukaschen bei dem alle Gesetze und
Flüchtlingskonvention nicht mehr gelten
befeuern diese menschenverachtende
Migrationspolitik der Europäischen Union
muss endlich beendet werden und die NGOs
brauchen dringend und so schnell wie
möglich Zugang damit sie den Menschen
helfen und unterstützen können weil die
Europäische Union und auch die
Bundesregierung systematisch in der
Migrationsfrage versagt und diese
menschenverachtende Flüchtlingspolitik
muss endlich beendet werden vielen Dank
das Wort erhält für eine Inter kurze
Intervention der Abgeordnete frohmeyer
von der AFD
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
es ist ja schon interessant wenn man
hier heute wieder zuhört und erstellt
sich sofort die Frage auch wenn man der
Vorrednerin zugehört hat wie viele
Personen würden Sie denn bei sich daheim
aufnehmen sie werben immer dafür dass
wir quasi eine Politik der offenen Tür
fortsetzen sollen dass man human sein
soll ich will sie fragen Fohlen wurde
von quasi eine Zuwanderung zur
europäischen Werten etc gesprochen wir
haben alleine wenn wir uns
beispielsweise in afrikanischen
Kontinent anschauen 1,2 Milliarden
Menschen zwei Drittel davon gelten als
ausreisewillig wollen Sie all diese
Leute dann quasi in die Europäische
Union und nach Deutschland bringen diese
Frage müssen Sie uns doch mal
grundsätzlich beantworten sie können und
das sage ich Ihnen als
entwicklungspolitiker die Probleme
anderer Länder nicht lösen indem sie
quasi beispielsweise diese Länder aus
denen jetzt migriert wird sie quasi alle
nach Deutschland holen Peter Scholler du
hat mal gesagt man Kalkutta nicht helfen
indem man Deutschland zu Kalkutta macht
und das ist doch das worauf man sich
endlich mal festlegen müsste versuchen
sie durch eine gute durch eine gute
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit die Situation
in Ländern vor Ort zu verbessern aber
hören Sie doch mal auf uns zu erzählen
dass wir die Probleme der Welt lösen
können indem wir die Welt nach
Deutschland bringen das wird nicht
funktionieren
das ist völlig absurd und dann
vielleicht zum Abschluss noch beenden
Sie doch einfach mal Interventionismus
es gibt doch einen Grund warum wir
weltweit Migrationsbewegungen haben und
die CDU lieber Kollege frei sie haben
doch Lukaschenko und Co gezeigt wie es
geht sie bezahlen doch bis heute
Schutzgeld an Erdogan dafür dass
illegale Migration nicht stattfindet vor
zwei Jahren als die AFD darüber
gesprochen hat dass Migration als Waffe
eingesetzt wird
für das Bundesamt für Verfassung ich
komme direkt zum Schluss heute sagt die
Europäische Union selber weaponization
of migration und das ist doch was gerade
stattfindet das muss beendet werden
Frau Kollegin hat wurde sie können
antworten sie müssen aber nicht
alles klar
komm nunmehr das Wort für die
SPD-Fraktion der Kollege Professor
er hat es getauft
okay vielen dank das hatte ich hatte
mich leider noch nicht erreicht dann
bekommt jetzt das Wort der Kollege Dr
Johann wadeful für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Entschuldigung
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin die
cdu/csu-fraktion nimmt ihre neue Rolle
als voraussichtliche
Oppositionsfraktion an und Herr Kollege
Stamm wir freuen uns immer wenn hier
auch Vertreter eine erfolgreiche
nordrhein-westfälischen Landesregierung
das Wort ergreifen aber ich muss schon
sagen wenn sie uns einerseits auffordern
die Oppositionsrolle anzunehmen und wir
dann argumentieren und der Kollege frei
hier auch die innenpolitische Debatte
führt dann darauf zu antworten wir
sollten hier nicht mit parteipolitischen
Spielchen anfangen da beißt sich also
die Katze in den Schwanz sie müssen
schon auch sie müssen schon auch wenn
wir Opposition machen sollen und das
werden wir machen dann werden wir hier
auch entsprechend auftreten dann werden
wir auch entsprechende Diskussionen hier
miteinander führen müssen das hat unser
Fraktionsvorsitzender heute
eindrucksvoll gezeigt und das hat auch
den Kollege frei für deutlich gemacht
also
Kuschelkurs Liebe
links gelbe Diskussionen die sich hier
auf den Weg mal Kuschelkurs wird mit der
cdu/csu-fraktion nicht geben sondern wir
tragen unsere
und dabei stehen wir natürlich vor der
schwierigen Aufgabe das Wissen hier alle
auch in diesem Hohen Hause der
Abgrenzung von der AFD aber heute ist es
noch einmal sehr deutlich geworden und
ich muss sagen Herr Kollege Curio was
sie hier wieder an politischer
Brunnenvergiftung geleistet haben hat
wirklich wieder dem fast den Boden
ausgeschlagen hier von Angreifern zu
sprechen wenn Menschen in der Tat in
einer schrecklichen Art und Weise von
einem Diktator eingesetzt werden als
Mittel politischer staatlicher Gewalt
dann von Angreifern zu sprechen finde
ich abenteuerlich und so schlimm die
Situation ist an allererster Stelle sind
es Menschen zu deren Hilfe und Schutz
wir Europäer verpflichtet sind Herr
Kollege cool ich würde meine Rede gerne
fortführen war es richtig ist die
Bundeskanzlerin auch Herrn Putin
angerufen hat und da gesagt hat dass
auch eher eine Mitverantwortung hat und
sie als die größten Verteidiger von
Herrn Putin könnten an dieser Stelle mal
einen einzigen Satz dazu sagen was die
russische Mitverantwortung für die
jetzige Situation ist da würde ich gerne
mal von ihnen was dazu hören Herr Putin
kann sofort stoppen fordern Sie ihn doch
mal dazu auf aber sie sind auch am
gängelbahn von Moskau und deswegen wagen
Sie es nicht dass hier entsprechend
aufzuführen meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren der Außenminister hat gesagt
dass es überfällig ist und ich muss
sagen Herr Maas das ist ja auch wir
haben ja die bisherige Bundesregierung
mitgetragen die jetzt geschäftsführend
im Amt ist das muss ich auch selbst
Anklagen sagen vier Monate macht Lukas
schenkow jetzt schon diese Aktion 50
Flüge pro Woche und nächste Woche will
die EU nun endlich mal etwas machen Herr
Außenminister ich muss sagen das muss
jetzt endlich bei allen Verhandlungen
die sie führen über die neue Koalition
das muss ihre Top-Priorität werden dass
diese Sache mit Belarus gestoppt wird da
muss die EU endlich ein Vorhand kommen
und wenn es so ist
frau Kollegin Brandner sie haben eine
Rede gehalten wo ich an vielen Stellen
zustimmen konnte wenn es so ist dass die
Grünen dafür sorgen werden dass die neue
linksgrüne Koalition links gelbe
Koalition darauf haben wir uns ja sie
ist auch sie ist auch grün wenn sie
dafür sorgen wollen dass es jetzt eine
harte Hand gegen Moskau gibt dann werden
Sie unsere Unterstützung haben dabei
werden wir Sie unterstützen machen sie
weiter dazu gehören auch zwei Prozent im
Bundeshaushalt für Verteidigungsausgaben
da wünschen wir Ihnen viel Erfolg und da
haben sie die Unterstützung der
cdu/csu-fraktion vielen Dank
Johann badepfuhl war das
stellvertretendervorsitzende der
Unionsfraktion und schon in der
Warteschleife ist Lars castellucci aus
der SPD-Fraktion der Bundestag
diskutiert nach wie vor über die
flüchtlingslage an den EU-Außengrenzen
speziell an der zwischen Polen und
Belarus liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
auf der Tagesordnung steht Migration
doch wir haben es mit einem Verbrechen
zu tun
wir haben es mit jemanden zu tun der
nicht nur sein eigenes Volk unterdrückt
sondern Menschen auf widerwärtigste
Weise anlockt als Druckmittel benutzen
will und ihm Niemandsland zurücklässt
und deshalb eine klare Aussage eine
klare Botschaft an Herrn Lukaschenko
Europa ist stärker wir haben es hier mit
staatlichen Menschenschmuggel zu tun und
wir werden alles dafür tun diesen
staatlichen Menschenschmuggel zu
unterbinden mit Einwirken auf Belarus
mit Einwirken auf die Länder wo die
Menschen herkommen mit Einwirken auf die
Fluggesellschaften wir haben staatlichen
Menschenschmuggel und wir werden das
nicht akzeptieren wir werden die Rechte
Europas hochhalten und das ist unsere
erste Aufgabe
ein Wort an die Union
Migration Steuern begrenzen ordnen so
lautet die Antrag
taufrisch ist diese Wahlperiode und
schon haben Sie Ihren Grundsatz der
letzten Wahlperiode diesen ungeliebten
Grundsatz der immer dazu kam über Bord
geschmissen die Humanität
aber ich sage Ihnen es geht wenn es um
Ordnung geht immer um beides es geht
nicht um irgendeine Ordnung sondern es
geht um eine Rechtsordnung und diese
Rechtsordnung erfordert
dass wir das Recht auch an den
europäischen Außengrenzen
aufrechterhalten und dazu gehört immer
und zu jeder Zeit die Menschenrechte
dazu und deswegen Humanität und Ordnung
gehören zusammen sie sind nicht trennbar
und lieber Herr frei oder erwartet
[Applaus]
linken viele Grüße von links grün oder
von links gelb oder von was auch immer
machen Sie sich mal keine Sorgen um die
Mitte passen Sie lieber auf dass ihr
nicht zu weit nach rechts rücken
Herr Kollege castellucci
Herr Kollege castellucci erlauben sie
eine Zwischenfrage der Kollegin nastic
nein Kolleginnen und Kollegen die an den
Außengrenzen in den an den Grenzregionen
unserer unseres Landes ihre Wahlkreise
haben haben wir berichtet dass es dort
zu abscheulichen Taten gekommen ist zu
menschenjagten das Waffen aufgefunden
wurden
das ist beschämend des abscheulich
und noch beschämender und noch
abscheulicher ist dass der verlängerte
Arm dieser rechtsextremen hier in diesem
Parlament sitzt und hier wieder solche
Reden gehalten wurden Herr kurio schämen
Sie sich einfach für ihre Rede
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wir haben Grundsätze
an den Außengrenzen Europas soll niemand
zu Tode kommen werden unsere
gaußengrenzen kommt soll menschenwürdig
behandelt werden wer nach Asyl nachfragt
der soll ein faires Verfahren erhalten
niemand soll zurückgeschickt werden wo
Tod und Verderben drohen das sind unsere
Grundsätze so steht es in der
Europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention
und so steht es seit 70 Jahren in der in
der Konvention was die Rechte von
Flüchtlingen angeht wir dürfen nicht
nachlassen für diese Rechte uns
einzusetzen dazu rufe ich uns alle auf
vielen Dank
das aus der SPD-Fraktion wenn die Liste
stimmt der vorletzte Redner in dieser
Debatte in der es um zwei Anträge geht
einerseits aus der afd-fraktion an der
andere aus der Unionsfraktion Thema ist
die flüchtlingslage an den
EU-Außengrenzen insbesondere die Lage
vor Polen wo ja durch das belarussische
Regime mutmaßlich
allerlei Flüchtlinge in Richtung EU
gelotst werden sollen jetzt gibt es doch
die Kurzintervention aus der
Linksfraktion das ist vollkommen richtig
und kritisieren es aber an der
polnischen Regierung sind die Gebrüder
in Geistern der AFD und das hier niemand
darüber spricht und es endlich
einfordert das internationale
BeobachterInnen dass
Menschenrechtsorganisationen von dieser
Regierung endlich ein freien Zugang
bekommen macht mich auch übrigens als
Polin wirklich traurig denn die
Regierung tut alles aber nicht den
Menschen in Not zu helfen in der
allgemein Aufklärung der Menschenrechte
hat man sich haben wir uns dazu
verpflichtet nicht zuletzt eine Frage an
alle die hier geredet haben aus
verschiedenen politischen Ecken es wird
darüber gesprochen woher die Menschen
kommen sie suchen Schutz es wird nicht
darüber geredet wieso sich fliehen dass
die Menschen aus den Jemen kommen dass
sie aus dem Irak kommen aus Syrien auch
viele koordinnen und Kurden dass diese
Menschen vor regime change und auch
teilweise vor Beteiligung der
natokriegefliehen und auch noch das in
den Staaten wie Saudi-Arabien und die
Kriegskoalition diese Kriege mit Waffen
aus deutschen aus Deutschland
ausgerüstet werden auch das sind
Verbrechen an diesen Menschen und
deswegen hat man erst recht die
Verantwortung sich hier aufzunehmen und
ihnen an der polnisch russischen
weißrussischen Grenze endlich zu helfen
vielen Dank Herr Kollege castolici mögen
sie antworten
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kollegin vielen Dank dass Sie
sich zu Wort gemeldet haben ich will
darauf reagieren ich finde sie müssen
aufpassen dass sie das Geschäft von
Herrn Lukaschenko der anstrebt Europa zu
spalten nicht hier selber auch noch mal
vorantreiben wir müssen als Europa
zusammenstehen in dieser Krise und
deswegen geht es jetzt nicht darum
Vorhaltungen zu machen sondern zu
gemeinsam Lösungen zu kommen
ich bin kein Freund von Mauern oder
Zäunen und den Dingen die da jetzt
wieder entstehen aber ich halte auch
nichts von dem Konzept ihrer Fraktion
das ist einfach für die choice geben
soll und weil das jeder kommen kann
unsere Überzeugung ist Migration braucht
gute Regeln und wir werden immer dort
helfen wo Hilfe nötig ist soweit es in
unseren Möglichkeiten steht das er
wünsche ich das wünsche ich mir und das
erhoffe ich mir als die Leitlinie
unserer neuen Bundesregierung vielen
Dank
vielen Dank nunmehr hat als letzte
Rednerin in dieser Debatte das Wort für
die cdu/csu-fraktion Andrea Lindholz
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in unserem
Antrag heute geht es um die
migrationspolitische Notlage an der
östlichen EU-Außengrenze der
weißrussische Diktator Lukaschenko
benutzt dort verzweifelte Migranten um
die EU zu spalten und das dürfen wir ihm
nicht durchgehen lassen wir sehen heute
in dieser Debatte wieder auch die
schwierigen Prozesse des Grenzschutzes
auf der einen Seite und natürlich die
Tatsache dass es immer auch um Menschen
geht das zu Migranten geht zunächst
einmal begrüßt es die Unionsfraktion
dass der geschäftsführende
Bundesinnenminister die Schleierfahndung
bereits ausgeweitet und die
Bundespolizei an der Grenze zu Polen
deutlich verstärkt hat unsere Sorge ist
aber dass Deutschland als Führungsnation
in der EU auf diese perfide Strategie
von lukaschen sehr Putin und Erdogan
nicht entschlossen genug reagiert die
alte Bundesregierung ist nicht mehr
wegweisend im Amt die neue
Bundesregierung die kommen wird ist es
noch nicht
Deutschland und die EU sie dürfen sich
nicht von den Machenschaften des
weißrussischen Diktators Lukaschenko
erpressen lassen wir müssen und dürfen
nicht nachlassen Migration weiterhin zu
ordnen zu steuern und zu begrenzen
deutschland ist nach wie vor
hauptzieland für irreguläre Migration
wir dürfen daher auch nicht wie es die
Ampel offensichtlich vorhat neue Anreize
durch Spurwechsel durch Erhöhung von
asylbewerberleistung oder Änderungen bei
der Staatsangehörigkeit schaffen weil
das damit schaffen wir neue Hoffnungen
und einen neuen Druck Richtung Europa
und Richtung Deutschland
Kollegin Lindholz erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage von den
unser Motto muss es sein Ordnung statt
Erpressung und nichts anderes falsches
Signale dürfen wir nicht zulassen in der
aktuellen Situation fordern wir von der
Bundesregierung eine Reihe von
Gegenmaßnahmen in unserem Antrag drei
davon möchte ich exemplarisch anreißen
erstens soll die EU Polen aber auch
Litauen und Lettland beim Schutz der
gemeinsamen Außengrenzen in jeder
Hinsicht unterstützen denn freie
Binnengrenzen gibt es nicht ohne sichere
Außengrenzen und ohne sichere
Außengrenzen gibt es auch keine Ordnung
in der Migration und wir dürfen unsere
polnischen Nachbarn mit diesem Akt der
hybriden Kriegsführung auch nicht
alleine lassen darauf hat bereits
Manfred Weber der evp-vorsitzende
hingewiesen Fraktionsvorsitzende
hingewiesen die Fluglinien und Staaten
müssen sanktioniert werden die dem
Regime in mint diese irreguläre
Migration ermöglicht dazu gehören auch
europaweite Lande und überflugverbote
und es ist überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehbar warum es jetzt Wochen
braucht bis hier gehandelt und reagiert
wird stattdessen falsche Visa
ausgesprochen nicht einmal kontrolliert
werden es muss hier Sanktionen geben und
die EU darf auch die Rückführung von
nicht-schutzberechtigten Personen muss
die forcieren und darf auch die
sekundärmigration vor allem nach
Deutschland
gelassen wir müssen diese
sekundärmigration wirksam unterbinden
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage
Deutschland hilft Deutschland Hilft wie
kein anderes Land weil der Aufnahme bei
der Integration bei der Hilfe vor Ort in
Krisengebieten darauf können wir stolz
sein darauf werden wir auch nicht
nachlassen aber was wir nicht
akzeptieren können ist das mit
kurzsichtiger Migrationspolitik neue
Anreize geschaffen werden und dass wir
mit nicht klaren schnellen und zügigen
Sanktionen Menschenleben auf Spiel
setzen und schmucklanddiktatoren und
Populisten in die Hände spielen das sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren in diesem
Parlament kann nicht unser Ansatz sein
und deswegen bitte ich Sie auch unserem
an zuzustimmen für eine Ordnung und für
eine Begrenzung und gegen diese Politik
der hybriden Kriegsführung
Andrea Lindholz war die letzte Rednerin
kommt aus der Unionsfraktion und Beatrix
von Storch hat gerade
aufmerksam gemacht auf sich weil sie
eine Zwischenfrage stellen wollte zu
einer Kurzintervention lässt sie sich
allerdings nicht hinreißen das würde
bedeuten dass dieser Tagesordnungspunkt
abgearbeitet ist mein Julian Parker
deine Zwischenfrage aus der Fraktion der
Grünen ich bin heute Nacht dort aus dem
Grenzgebiet zurückgekommen und ich habe
gesehen wer dort an der Grenze steht das
sind keine Waffen das sind Menschen das
sind Menschen die teilweise sechs Mal
zurückgebracht worden sind zurück in die
Arme von Lukaschenko in die Arme der
brutalen Einheiten die dort an der
Grenze stehen darum geht es das sind